That's insane.
At what point is it totally unethical for Richard Spencer to
carry on his relationship with his Asian wife, okay, while also
claiming to be a white supremacist? At what point can we no longer
take Richard Spencer seriously?
Okay, I trusted this mother. These are brownies.
Like, no, they're not. Why are you doing this? I don't don't
do that. What are you doing? Why are you trying to fool me? are
the one >> man's in a room full of morons. No, I don't
think so. I is not a [__] You can't say there are
no content restrictions at all. There's not it's not pushing
anything at all and then go look, there's one person who is allowed
to criticize Gaza. So then IR's got no problem with any of the
money in politics then, right? He just thinks like you like there's
no reason to disclose anything. Like actually, we should get
rid of all individual contribution limits. Why are those even
Okay, we got 20 minutes left. I'm probably gonna go fire up Live
and Learn and check out the Lib andLearn chorus section. We'll
talk through some of it. Uh I could probably watch that through
Pisco's Hour, right? I think and watch that through Pisco's Hour.
I Oh, here's Lib and Learn. Yes, this guy right here.
>> Got Soy Pill and IRI must be filling in for Josiah.
Very interesting. Okay, I'm interested in this. Uh guys, if we
want to add more time to the stream, I'm probably going to cover
They do an hour and a half. I'll probably cover the whole hour
and a half if it's just an hour and a half. >> You're in
Are we live yet? >> Soy pills world now. >> Yeah.
Wait, so who's gonna take on the >> thought I was the fifth
horseman now? Uh well, I don't know. It seems like Josiah is
the other person on here. They might have filling in for Josiah.
I know Soy Pill, I think, is the person taking Connor Boy's place.
>> If if you're doing the actual stream, does that mean
Soy Pill is the guy or is Hutch cuz he's has the greatest
>> To be dude, Soy Bill, I feel like he's got the risk,
man. Not that not that I want to pass the buck. If you guys want
me to do it, I'll >> um unless unless possibly Josiah is
not doing live and learn anymore, but I can't see that. I feel
like I would have heard about that. >> Um you I think you
have a very strong
>> Oh, I I've heard I I'm being told okay through the wire
that I is a permanent member and Josiah is currently on
So no Josiah for a while. I replacing Josiah. Josiah on vacation.
>> We're gonna take on this next topic, but I can lead
into it >> because what we're gonna do first here, we're
gonna talk about this chorus
>> right? So, I think you've got a lot of opinions on this,
Hutch, and I'll let you lead the discussion, but uh I will introduce
uh guys. Hello. Hello, everyone. This is live and learn minus
one. Josiah is quitting live and learn forever. He's never coming
back. Uh no, he is uh taking Labor Day off. I'm sure he's spending
time with his family or, you know, receiving some sort of dark
money deal and and and reworking it. So, he can't be here today,
but I am temporary guest hosting. Uh, even though I'm also a
co-host, so technically I'm always a host. Um, but with us as
always, as every single episode are Peace, Go Hutch, and IRI.
Welcome, welcome, welcome everybody.
>> Next time, Queeners make fun of anyone else's countries.
Going to show them this some UK stuff. Some some Bongerville
stuff. What's going on with the Bongers? Local business owner
being interviewed live on UK TV. Interrupted by passer by hauling
racist abuse. Hurling, I believe, hurling racist
>> That's the issue we have you in our in our country.
You got our kids.
I'm going to get these people off stream before Quimman ends,
raids me, and then comes on stream to break to a thousand times
about what he'd do with these people and get this off stream
real quick. Okay, >> I would I don't want to I don't I
do not want to hear the things Queen would do to those people.
Okay. >> How was your weekend, guys? >> Be very disturbing.
Okay. >> A lot of wonderful times were had. Had some ice
cream. Everything was good.
>> This [__] is this pie again? Did he just
say ice cream? I had some ice cream. They're very drunk. Okay.
Okay. >> Times were had
some ice cream. Everything was >> some ice cream. I had
some ice cream.
Oh, the Brits were very drunk. Not Pisco. Pisco is supposed to
be sober. I don't know if Pisco is sober. Okay. Ice cream. He's
having some ice cream.
>> Yeah. I got to go on stage in front of 8,000 people.
Join the Offspring for a show on Friday. That was cool. >> Help,
bro. >> Hold on. Let's Let's dive into that a little. We
all know that I is the guy, right? The the guy who's pretty fly.
We all know that, right? We all know that this is Ira from the
favorite song from your youth. Yeah. I always sometimes I forget
that people don't know that. So I I like have to remember to
be like, "Oh, I don't know.
I don't know if people necessarily know this. I don't believe
you." Pull up the credits. Yeah. I don't think I don't think
he considers it doxingham, right? Cuz he's in um he's in rat
race. This is who he is. But I don't know if I can pull him up.
I'm trying to find a picture of him from something else. I don't
know if I can find it. It is him 100%. He was an actor. He's
in Rat Race and
he's in like one or two other things. I think he's just like
a He was an actor in LA for a while. It's all well known. Yeah,
I think so. Like if you look at his I still don't want to pull
it up. Okay. I'm I'm going to take the I'm going to chill on
that one. Just watch. He is the guy. That's why he was on.
>> Uh last time we did it like a decade ago. This time
I got hit up by the the lead singer. I've been friends with him
for a while. And once in a while we just talk and he's like,
"We have a show coming up in LA in a few weeks. We think it'd
be really fun for you to come on stage in the outfit." And so
they made me like a custom one cuz I have the original but it's
in a frame. And um so I just came out and came on stage and it
was a lot of fun. >> That's awesome. >> What What
is that like? Is it just like a fat adrenaline rush or what?
I mean >> I think he's like I think he's actually like
close friends with one of the members of the band or maybe the
whole band, right? So, I think like he actually does just go
to shows and he doesn't even necessarily perform. Like they invite
him when they're around his neck of the woods. I guess when they're
I think when they're in LA, they usually invite him to the concert
is my understanding. I mean, it's a whole experience cuz like
I go to the the like his house and I get to like hang out with
the rock stars and like I rode with him in a bus to the venue
and you know, we get to talk and then you know you're just said
Dexter >> backstage and it's it's just like everything
you can imagine, you know, and then it's Yeah, it's just a big
rush getting on stage and >> being in front of all those
people. It's >> The full body high. >> Yeah. I got
to be careful. I'm getting old so I had to stretch and stuff
get, you know, warm up. I think it's a trick for the audience
just because it's like they don't expect to see a character on
screen like from screen to stage, you >> And it's probably
like a ton of like millennials and Gen X, right? So, they probably
remember that video, huh? >> Yeah. And everybody told me
I look the same, which is so weird. They're like, "Have you guys
been keeping that guy frozen and not letting him age or what's
going on?" >> That's a compliment, bro. That's a big compliment,
man. >> Wait, how old are you? >> I'm 45. >> But
just if people don't know, I played >> Wait, he actually
might be 45. No, he is 45. He is unironically 45.
Yeah, I'm not joking cuz I looked at his IMDb. His IMDb has his
birthday on it. He is actually 45. 1980. That's crazy. Yeah,
he does not look 45. At least not on camera. >> The character
of the 45. >> I am 45 now.
>> When I was 18, I was uh >> It's not like I think
he's in his 20s, but he looks like, you know, he looks mid-30s.
I You might even be able to say early 30s, like 32 to 36. >> Started
my acting career and I did it for quite a few years and I got
this role as the Prett Fly guy in the offspring pretty fly for
a white guy. So that's what we're talking about. You do definitely
look pretty pretty young a little bit since I've only known you
a few weeks. >> Yeah, my face is a little heavier. I was
looking at like myself in the outfit and I definitely look a
little older, but it it's it's still pretty close. >> Oh
my god, that is you. What the hell? >> Dude, when I first
found out I I was like in rejection mode. I didn't want to believe
it, but it was true. And and as >> Dude, yeah, maybe Quimman
isn't that I don't know if you guys know. Okay, Queen needs to
This is what you have to go do your pilgrimage to the Holy Land
for. Okay. IRI 0% aging. All right. 45year-old looks 30. Queman.
going gray at like 12 is coming to grips with that. It's like
that's it's sick that they still have a relationship with you,
man. >> Can I cherish? >> Yeah, I really cherish
it because it's I'm a fan of the band and always wasn't. So,
it's just cool to see. >> Yeah. Look at this.
>> Look at it, bro. >> Oh, now I feel bad for pulling
up on their [__] >> No, I thought he was too.
>> Yeah, I thought he was fully trolling the first time
he told me that and then I looked it up on stream. I was like,
>> yeah, it's crazy. >> All right, boys. >> That
was fun. >> Let's uh let's dive into some topics. There's
some some memes going on with Trump dying. We got some some controversy
with this chorus, what have you. Um, >> let's do let's
do the chorus thing first cuz I think you're going to have a
lot to say about it. >> I've seen I've seen you're parading
yourself all over Twitter and I'm I'm furiously liking all of
the tweets because I I just think your opinions are so objectively
correct. >> I mean, I'm just I don't know about you guys.
I'm just pretty about the whole thing. Um, you know, Brian Tyler
Cohen, I would consider him to be one of the one of like the
stronger voices in the space. Uh, he's somebody that avoids drama.
I've never seen him like denigrate other creators. uh immediately
after the election, he was speaking a lot about the asymmetry
in alternative media between conservatives and liberals and progressives,
specifically with funding. He he was pointing to ventures like
TPUSA that pull in, you know, $80 million a year of private funding
and they're going out there and and it's hard to argue that TPUSA
is not having an impact when we look at these demographic shifts.
Are they responsible for all of it? Probably not. But I think
it's naive to suggest that. >> Oh, I should actually do
a full shield here real quick, guys. Guys, if you like the content,
go ahead, follow on every platform. Follow on Twitch. twitch.tv/jdlk
TV/JSLK_x.com/jdstlk_.
All right, join the Discord.
Join the Discord. Get in the community, okay?
And if you really like the content, go ahead and sub or donate
because it adds more time to the stream. All right? There's a
couple ways you can donate and get more time on the stream. All right?
You can sub on kick. You give subs on kick. You can sub on Twitch.
You can give primers on Twitch. All right? If you go over to
twitch.tv/jdk_,
you can give me your primer. You can give your primer to me.
Really appreciate it. All right. You can throw down the exclamation
point donate command in the chat. All right. That'll give you
the kickbot links. Okay. There's kickbot. There's Streamlabs.
These are the TTS links. You buy a TTS message. And last but
not least, there's the Patreon. patreon.com/jsk.
Go sign up for any of these things to show your support for the
stream. Um, everything but the Patreon goes towards more time
on the stream. I really appreciate you guys and all the support
you give. All right. We're I think we're seven subs away for
another hour on the stream right now. And I I think we'll go
through probably most of the chorus stuff here no matter what.
But you know, you should pay for the time because you really
love supporting the channel >> that what they're doing
is not having an impact if not for any other. >> And so
then you have someone like BTC who uh you know, as you were speaking
to a piece, I saw you were commenting on I watched a little bit
of your conversation with Aaron. Uh BTC was uh Brian Takone was
was pretty open about what this thing was like before it was
made. And you have this guy that's like he didn't even take a
salary. Like he was just doing it for the love of the game. He
was devoting ostensibly like hours of his week. uh devoted to
a program that was meant to mentor >> what
I I don't know which part this is relevant to. I don't think
anybody's arguing that nobody understood that course was funding
people, right? That's not the argument here. That's not the argument
at all. >> Fund and uplift. >> The argument to me,
there's a couple arguments. Okay. One is there appears to be
something that's that was in the contract language that said
you cannot disclose this partnership.
Now, they had to clear this up with Chorus, but apparently there
was a webinar or something where they posted and they said here
are some pre-approved ways that you can talk about the partnership
or maybe can't disclose the partnership without written consent.
one of these two things, right? Now, saying you can't do something
without written consent of the other party is saying you you
require our permission, right? So, preventing disclosures or
requiring permission for disclosures, that's probably not great.
Uh I've not seen anybody actually refute that. I've only seen
people say, "Well, technically before those contracts were offered
or signed, we actually
disclose that we were partnered with them." That's not the same
thing. That is stupid. You look like a when you say when you
say this and you don't understand that the disclosure has to
come with the money being offered and not just that you're working
with this thing to try to get it bootstrapped, right? That there
is a difference between you getting money from these people and
signing a contract that says you can't disclose something and
just being generically partnered with them or working with them
in some way. Oh, you guys want to send me a video of IRI being
on stage with the offspring? Sure. You know anyone who >> I
got you. I want to bring up someone very special for you guys
on the stage right now and help us with the next part. Please
come up. Pretty Fly Guy, please come up. >> This is the
real deal, right? >> Is that Is it the real Pretty Fly
Guy right now?
We got a shotgun. Oh yeah, that's him.
Right now.
>> Yes. That's what I'm talking about. He knows what's
going on. We're just noticing how loud it is out here. for you
especially, right? I don't know if you can hear me. Check out
Check out how loud these guys are over here right now. You hear
me? Pretty good, right? Of course. You know, right in front of
us are super loud. You can always hear that. They're right here,
right?
>> This is cracking up. You know, there's people back there.
I can barely see them, but I can hear >> Oh, yeah. I forgot.
They They always do this when they do the song. They have like
the wacky
uh the inflatable wacky wacky waving inflatable arm flailing
tomb. man. Is that the Is that the name from Family Guy? They
always get these guys out there, too.
>> All right. Anyway, cool. Cool. Good times. Good time.
>> Like smaller creators. Like he actually like walked
the walk in a way that I haven't really seen anybody else in
the space do. And then this article comes out. I'm just curious
to hear, you know, I'm actually especially curious to hear what
you have to say about this piece go cuz I think you might be
more familiar with uh contracts and these sort of things. So,
why don't why don't you open this conversation up with your sort
of summary of the article. Did you have any issues with it? Yeah.
Well, let me start with what I think to be a genuine critique
and one that I think is is worth talking about, which is I think
there should be a social norm among commentators to disclose
revenue streams related to their content. I don't think that
that's a bad thing to point out. And I said on on my Twitter
that I think that it's a mistake to the extent that they weren't
disclosing um that they were receiving funds from Chorus. I take
that to be a genuine mistake um and something that, you know,
should be rectified. I don't think that it should be overstated
or we should bend out of shape about it, but I just think as
a social norm should be disclosed and that applies to any kind
of funny stream related to your content just for appearances
and so there's no, you know, appears of a conflict of interest
or that people you have access to um potential biases, you know,
and so it's an even playing field. I don't say anything more
than that. But other than that, I kind of find the the discourse
around the piece um and the piece itself to be riddled with falsehoods,
um disingenuous narratives, and um frankly, >> I find it
pretty reprehensible or at >> I could say there are disingenuous
narratives. Uh one is the Israel one, the one we called out from
the beginning, right? The the Israel one was pretty annoying
to me, just like cuz it it's just a good way of like discrediting
yourself amongst most serious people. If you immediately attribute
something to Israel or before you actually look into it at all,
excuse me. Um, that just looks goofy, makes you look goofy. It's
easily easy to discredit you. You shouldn't do that as a first
step before, you know, looking both ways. Make sure >> some
aspects of it. Um, I'll give you a couple examples of what I'm
talking
>> So, I I do want to ask just on principle as someone
who has received now financial help from Progressive Vicory one
time. Um, and they might give me more later in the future. Um,
but they were, you know, helping me out. They they gave me some
money so I could get some more editing equipment so that I could
edit on the road while I was with Roana, who they also connected
me with. And my question is um I don't think I've ever like made
a video that's like hey just FYI everyone progressive victory
gave me some money for a laptop so I could edit. Um but if anyone
asks I'll say it. Uh what's the decorum like every time anyone
decides they want to you know help me out be if it's greater
than a super chat I have to then declare that someone is helping
me uh
how would you do this? So man they did it and they connected
you with Roana. I feel like there should be something there saying
like uh yeah, progressive victory help me out here. Probably,
right? Probably. Yeah, that is a difference, Cringleish.
Like I I do think like probably you should disclose that if you
don't if you like forget to and it's like not really meaningful.
Like if it's if it's not that much money, right? Like if it's
helpful but it's not that much money, I don't know if you need
to say anything, right? And I would just expect it to be kind
of similar to if you got a big super chat, right? you like if
you got a $500 super chat, you kind of like go into like I talked
about um I just don't understand why you wouldn't bring it up.
Like if if people don't know from early on the stream, BB Poison
sent me a whole computer. Like I literally my streaming PC the
entire time I've streamed, the entire time I've had a streaming
PC, I haven't been on a MacBook, which I used to only stream
from my MacBook. The entire time I stream from a PC has been
from a PC that BB Poison sent me, right? probably like between
1,200 and 2K for the PC. Um, if I were to buy it off of him,
I it must have been like 2K new, right? So, he sent me like a
whole streaming PC, but I talk about this all the time. So, I
don't know. I think probably you just trade it like you would
a big super chat where like you announce it, you say like this
is a big deal. Yeah, we got I got money. Who even is that guy?
I I found out about him through Wick TV. The Soy Pill. I think
he's like a big creator. He's got like a different channel that's
kind of big, doesn't he? Right. Soy Pill. Soy pill. The soy pill.
He's got like 125k subs on YouTube, but I think it was like
>> It was like Yeah, it was like a different kind of channel
or something before, right? I don't even know what this is.
I don't know. I don't know what the content was before. Just
whatever he wanted to talk about at any given time. Cool.
I don't This isn't Oh, no. Maybe this is his politics channel
or something. No, he's got a different politics channel, right?
Streaming vods channel. Soy pill streams. He does something else,
too. Okay, that doesn't make sense. I don't know where he came
from. I don't know. I think he did some other kind of content.
He's like Hutch. He like transitioned in. You BP fund you, bro.
BB talking points. Shaking my damn head.
No, trust me. Porter Beller is in that group. He's not going
to let me do BB talking points. Okay. The article itself doesn't
claim they can't talk about Israel. That was added by people
after it was out. Yes, Porter Beller. I'm saying that Pisco just
talked about I was responding to Pisco saying that he doesn't
like some of the narratives around this, surrounding this.
You see it's not announced the be purge. No, I didn't see that.
But not shocking. These people bite the head. >> Even if
it has nothing to do with like my ideas or a video being made
like I >> I think you're probably right that there's some
dimminimous threshold. But I think that in the main this is not
something that you're going to disagree with other than maybe
some some dimminimous uh programs or some, you know, one-off
super chats where there's there's not an expectation of return
obligations, right? A super chat is like a donation. Um and the
money is sent before there can be a return obligation, but you
know, a contract, which this is is a contract, is bilateral.
Oh, this is a fantastic uh this is a fantastic point for Pisco
to make because I already get to see a wavy 99. Thank you for
the two months. Okay, I get to see now how people are going to
react to this, right? Because this is a great point that when
people do the argument, okay, this totally disingenuous argument
about, oh, you should do you just have to disclose all your super
chats.
There is no quid proquo. There is no there is no thing they can
demand of you when they send a super chat. All right, except
maybe more time in the stream in my case. Although not even necessarily.
45, 44, 43. I'm getting out of here the second that clock hits
zero, by the way. I'm out. I'm out. I'm probably not out. Um,
there's nothing they can demand of you. Obviously, when you sign
a contract and there is there are some obligations,
right? That's way way way different. If Progressive Victory said,
"Here's some money." The guy who runs Progressive Victory says,
"Here's some money, soy pill. Don't worry about it. Never you
don't never have to do anything for me. I just like your content.
Here you go. That's almost maybe it went through progressive
victory somehow. That's almost approaching a super chat. That's
like as long as you just say like thank you or something, you
know, seems fine. >> There are uh you know obligations
that are being put forth and expectations from the other side
as well. And so yeah, I would maybe put some diminished threshold,
but I don't think in general you'd have a disagree with the social
norm like so I'll just ask you directly. If I were being paid
by breaking points for my appearances, don't you think that that's
something I should disclose? if I had uh you know financial relationships
with breaking. >> This is this is the easiest argument
in the world and Pisco hits it again. This is just the progressive
victory argument I gave counterpoints almost two year not quite
almost two years ago like a year and a half ago now. What if
progressive victory was funded by Peter Teal? Don't you think
that would be important for you to know? Go look at the people
they fund. Go look at the crazy embarrassing people they used
to fund. Okay, these like super far leftists who don't leave
their houses ever. All right, go look at that. What if Peter
Tal was funding this and just trying to make progressives look
f it's like oh yeah no I would want that disclosed like that
would be really bad it's like okay so we agree disclosures are
good
good I'm glad >> points or hell with the culture war with
Tim Pool don't you think that's as a social norm that's something
I should >> it depends like if you're if you're being compensated
for example Tim Pool paid to fly me out they paid for my hotel
um I like Right I know but I'm saying like those things like
I'd never
>> immediately into like just stupid things that have nothing
to do with this. >> I said those uh like as like I felt
obligated to. It's just like yeah, of course. So some people
don't by the way like some people uh Roana's team didn't pay
for me to uh you know go with them. I had to do all that out
of pocket. So it's like okay well sometimes I get paid for but
if they were saying but if they were saying here's $10,000 to
come on our show I think you should say it in so far as this
could have an >> no uh Pisco
Height on what you're saying >> 100%. So so so example
I'm going to give you an example. Let's say Hassan [__]
>> He's not even doing the like I'm giving you money and
this might affect your opinion. That's not what Pisco is saying.
Pisco is saying if somebody says I'll give you money if you sign
this contract that gives me some power over you that there is
some return benefit to me, right? That I there's a an agreement
before us. I have some leverage within this agreement. You've
agreed to do things for me, right? Some signed agreement. Then
is that is that something you should disclose? He's not even
going to the like, oh well, if you got if he got something, there's
like no quid proquo there. there's nothing that I get in return.
He's not even saying that one. >> Paid me $2,000 a month
to appear on his show and to talk about legal issues. Do you
think I should disclose that? >> Yeah, I would say so.
Yeah. >> Okay. And and if [__] was doing some
kind of incubator program where he was uh you know getting up
and lefty people and and training them up and saying these are
the good messaging, you would also say as a social norm that
should be disclosed. Correct. >> Yeah, that makes sense
to me. >> Okay. So, it sounds like and I want to know if
there's any disagreements on this panel to the extent that Taylor
Ren's critique and we're going to evviscerate Taylor Ren's article
in a second. So, don't be worried about that. To the extent and
only to the extent that Taylor's critique is these people should
have disclosed their income streams. I think everyone here related
to their content again putting forth like the dimmin dimminus
limits whatever you want to say those specials are but I think
$8,000 a month that some content creators for getting that passes
that do we all agree that that is something that should be disclosed
>> I mean I think like
Hutch can't make that totally reasonable concession hold on a
second you just give an entirely reasonable position that I should
obviously concede to did I just sense a totally bullet I might
be able to bite >> the the the general rule of dumb is
probably to like air on the side of caution and and um like overdisclose
like you can't can't get in trouble for doing that because I
think that the problem here is like the appearance of the potential
for like corrupt influence or something like that. >> Oh,
I got to eat some crow. I got to eat some crow. It doesn't sound
like he's actually disagreeing. I got to eat some crow in that.
My bad, Hutch. I went I went in on you a little too early. Okay,
you're my boy Hutch. I'm sorry that I did that. I'm sorry. I
was wrong to go in so hard on him. >> Um you were talking
to Ira. What do you >> I say no. I'm sorry. I I understand
>> Oh, well, thank God I did it. >> It's for the
greater good, but is it absolutely necessary? No, I don't think
so. And I don't think Why should it change anything for people
to disclose? What if there's a guy who comes to my channel and
donates $1,000 a month? Should I disclose that? >> Yeah.
So, so
I just not listening. Many people have this this this problem.
They just can't listen. They don't hear anything the other person
says. I have this problem sometimes. I think I'm a little better
than some, especially if I'm like trying to focus up for stream.
the entire if you want to complain just leave messy table. If
you don't want to watch this you don't have to. So the problem
some people have Pisco is saying if if there's an agreement reached
it's not like and and like I have some obligation to the other
party. I have an obligation to them. That guy was paying you
$1,000 a month. You have some obligation to them. Then yeah,
you should probably disclose that.
>> Well I I think the expectation as I explained before
is one in which there's a contract. A contract is a meeting in
the minds in which there's, you know, a mutual you're mutually
being bound by something. You know, a donation is a onetime thing.
There is perhaps there's some sort of social expectation, but
there's no formal requirement that I uh to give some obligation
back, right? >> right, it's not about like the legality
of peace or I think what the issue is is if it comes out and
you've been hiding it this whole time and it's from someone who
would otherwise be someone that you are maybe disagreeing with
or you propose, you purport to agree or disagree with and it's
like, wait, are you doing this for money? Because you were hiding
this. So now it comes into question your character and like what
what kind of content you make. Like I understand that there is
this sort of like social expectation of hey if the dem like and
let's say
let's say you're here's the hypothetical right maybe so pill
is about to say this or he is saying this kind of the hypothetical
for soy pill here is what if you take a bunch of money from a
group and you actually have your mind changed by people in that
group totally legitimately. you never disclose it and then because
you've been hanging out with that group, you've had your mind
changed. You can argue the points completely, but now because
you didn't disclose it, it comes out, you know, six months later
and people see your content, take a huge bend towards, let's
just do the hypothetical that everyone wants to do the most.
You're suddenly pro- Israel, like really pro-Israel when you
weren't before, but you feel like you've changed entirely normally
and you haven't disclosed that. Like, holy [__] how
are you going to get your credibility back? Right? It looks like
you just got paid to show for Israel. you're you're hooked. Democrat
party is giving you this much money. Like, how do we know that
you're going to hold them to account? Now, to be clear, in this
story specifically, a bunch of these people totally criticize
the Democrats. People are trying to use the stories to say like
this is why so many of these
uh this is like the idea that one person or two people involved
in this, let's say three, I think I've seen so far out of this
like 80 to 90 person program have ever criticized Democrats.
Is that really proof that this isn't pushing the party line in
some way? No, obviously not.
It's not totally
but like I don't even think for these things that you're supposed
to have I don't think you can have like very strict filtering
guidelines for some of these programs if you want to remain a
501c4,
right? Although I'm screwing that up. Chorus is not a 501c4.
If you want to remain like um if you want to remain eligible
to collect funds from I think a 501c4 or something. I can't I
need to go look up the structure again. It's getting late. My
bad. Or chorus is a 501c4. Okay, whatever. I think if you want
to remain a 501c4. Yes. Okay. I think you need to be nonpartisan,
right? Need to be technically nonpartisan, which is why they
say our goal is like uh pro- freedom content, pro-democracy content,
rather. I mean, a lot of them are lefty as Tik Tockers. Okay,
that's fine. Is their broad makeup of positions that they support
mostly, and I'm going to say 95% align with the Democrat party,
right? focused on advocacy, not electioneering. I think the issue
here for me, internet ray, is the clear purpose of chorus when
it started and this can happen and all they have to do is explain
it. But but the clear purpose of chorus when it started was to
do messaging for the Democrats. The DNC does not know how to
message correctly. They don't sorry, it's maybe multiple things.
One of them is messaging for Democrats. Guys, Brian Tyler Cohen
says, "Guys, have you ever gotten the impression that when news
hits, it's like the Republicans had a morning meeting? If you've
ever felt like that, well, that's going to change now cuz we
have chorus now. We're going to get everybody on the same page
right away with talking points. We're going to make sure that
we get our voices out there, right? So, it's obviously talking
about being the Democratic Party's messaging or doing the Democratic
Party's messaging. And then the second point was these big politicians
won't connect with independent media. They don't connect with
independent media. We need to fix that. We need to make sure
they know that they need to. We need to make sure that they know
that they can create like um evangelists, right? They can create
missionaries for their platforms and their perspectives if they
could just give some legitimacy to some of these smaller channels.
They create like die hards forever.
The best example of this I can think of is when Infowars was
small. Alex Jones just was, you know, a humble water filter salesman.
Donald Trump went on his program, totally legitimized it, supercharged
that guy's business. That guy has gone to bat for Trump every
single time that there's been a question about Trump. He's gone
to bat for him for a decade now, right? It's a solid decade of
Alex Jones stepping up to the plate and defending Donald Trump
on anything.
And Brian Tyler Cohen was like, "You guys, Kamala Harris, why
don't you go to smaller channels? Why don't you do this?" Right?
Why won't you do this? So that that those are the two things
politicians aren't willing to interact with this media. We need
to get these connections working. We need to make sure that they
know to go on these small channels. we need to make sure that
we can network with them. And then the other one was the messaging
part. Both things have to do with Dems. And so when Brian Tyler
then, you know, a couple months later when they when they found
the the company and it's a 501c4 and they can't be Democrat affiliated,
he's suddenly going, I don't spent any time thinking about the
DNC.
Don't lie to me. Don't make me look Don't make me feel stupid,
right? You're just lying to me. Could you just dodge the question
at least? Don't lie. Just don't lie. It's it's [__]
>> influencers won't criticize Israel when we'll get to
that. Yeah, we'll get into that. But I think it it's like um
if someone's paying you that much like and you are making videos
about topics that you know specifically are downstream of those
people's politics, you probably should say like by the way these
people give me money. Now to be clear people and I if I was going
to steal man this side's arguments, I don't know if we're going
to make it through this by the way guys. Um I don't know how
much we're going to make it through this because I'm probably
going to take off in just a little while. But um if I had to
steal their argument, it should be something like this. T Loren's
published an article. It leans in a direction. It's not It's
the direction it leans in, I think, is disingenuous, but the
factual reporting is accurate. What makes the article disgusting
is that she goes on and does interviews with people like Glenn
Greenwald and she retweets people who imply that like they're
using this to quell criticism of Israel and and [__]
like this, right? That they're going to go around and do things
like this. She's going to go on shows and she's going to add
context to her article that wasn't there that Wire didn't accept
like the stuff about like, you know, quelling, you know, outcries
against Israel, you know, cutting down pro Palestinian creators
and [__] like this. She's going to go and add that
context after the fact without wired uh like without the wired
editorial staff. and she's using the the wired editorial staff
as useful idiots to to put an article out there that while factual
is painting the wrong picture and then she's adding on to that
picture later and painting just a totally disingenuous picture,
a really up picture. That would that would be my argument if
I were them. But what they've done is said the article is totally
debunked. There's a bunch of lies in it and Taylor Loren is a
hypocritical and that's just not really the answer. That's not
really I don't think that's answering in good faith at all. It's
sad. I I really hate how misleading a lot of the reporting on
this is because everyone's like, "Yeah, all these creators getting
8,000 a month." Like, first of all, that was the cap. Second
of all, there's a bunch of different things that people could
be paid for. And my understanding is some people, something like
uh uh like uh David Pacman or BTC, I don't think they're getting
paid 8,000 a month to just exist in this thing and go to these
trainings. If anything, they're helping and they're part of the
mentorship program, right? And then you've got smaller creators
that are getting paid a lot less to, you know, hey, make some
content like every week, you know, make a short, you know, make
sure you're improving your game. We're trying to expand your
ideas. Like this is a widespread thing. And I don't know if you
would have to disclose like, hey, I'm part of a training program,
right? Like it really depends on. >> Yeah, I'm not saying
that. I just want to be clear about what I'm saying before I
responds. Like I'm not
>> I think it's important to disclose because it's not
just a training program. There are daily messaging check-ins.
Okay. And there's weekly advocacy trainings where you get like
policy training like I literally the the thing we got from Alli
said we go deep on some policy position or something right from
someone who is aligned with who is probably aligned with Democrats
like it is going to be it's a progressive agenda it's going to
be more Democrat aligned right you're basically spending about
an hour to an hour and a half a week with creators educating
them on how like Brian Tyler Cohen thinks for example Right.
So, to me, that's a big part of this that when you say they're
being paid to p push the the party line, that's probably what
they're referring to, right? You have to go to these things.
These are mandatory meetings. The I believe the advocacy training
and the daily uh the daily messaging check-ins are mandatory.
You have to go to them, right? So, that is a that is a fact that
nobody's really keying in on for some reason, right? Like if
I if I told you that you're going to get an hour and a half of
mandatory like messaging updates from Hassan [__]
would you think I'm pushing a a certain lens of political thought
or would you think, "Oh, there's nothing really bad there. There's
nothing really questionable there." I think all of these guys
would say, "Oh, obviously there's something like I don't like
that." Wait, Hassan's paying you money and he's going to tell
you like he's going to tell you about policies. He's going to
tell you what policies are best and he's going to give you like
messaging updates every day. Oh, I don't like that. I don't like
that at all. is I believe what most people would say >> saying
you disclose the amount. I'm not saying you disclose other contract
terms, but the mere fact if if there's a formal relationship
with with the contract and mutual expectations, I'm not saying
anything else about the article is accurate or true. I just think
that there ought to be a social norm and IRA. I I think that
you would grant that like if I were being paid thousands of dollars
by Hassan [__] for a same kind of incubator program
that you would feel that I should disclose that because then
people are going to say, "Well, the only reason he's not criticizing
Hassan on Global Entry stuff or on this or that is because he's
getting paid." And I think that that's that's something that
you would expect. >> Uh, not necessarily. I I think, you
know, because to me it's like people are projecting
what they think these creators are going to do with that money.
And if Hassan's paying you to come on his show, Peace Go, I trust
you that you're going to stick to your guns and that you're going
to give your And you know, I think I trust my doctor. Okay. My
doctor took an oath. All right. My doctor took an oath. And when
they prescribe me opiates for a broken leg, even knowing that
the mortality rate of those opiates is way higher than any pain
issue from my broken leg, I trust them to have my best interest
at heart, despite the fact that they're getting paid tens of
thousands of dollars by some [__] pharmaceutical
company to offer me those drugs. Right. Sorry, I saw I saw a
straighter in the chat and I had to steal talking point. Okay.
Right. Oh, that that doesn't need to be disclosed. I don't care
if my doctor's getting paid tens of thousands, hundreds of thousands
of dollars to recommend certain drugs. Why would I care if they
disclose that? They're going to have my best interest at heart.
Right? Surely they won't take somebody nearly doubling their
income and give them the benefit of the doubt and push some drugs
that might not be the best for me. Right? Right. We should just
trust everybody that way. Definitely shouldn't get anybody to
disclose anything, guys. True opinion. You're not going to be
motivated by the money. You're just appreciate that he's paying
you for your time to be there to give your opinion and be yourself.
That's how I see it. I sitting here like, listen, I realize
I
how do we put this? Okay, I operating as if he doesn't understand
human nature at all. That's a little crazy to me. Okay, that's
a little crazy. I'm not going to go hop in a cage with a lion
that's at the zoo. Oh, it's never attacked anybody before. Why
would I think the lion might attack me? Why would I think the
lion might attack me, guys? Oh, they've beded a couple days.
Why would I think you'd attack me? I don't know. Uh people,
>> dude, people
follow money. Okay, it just is what it is, man. >> So,
I don't know where what like why Taylor went off on this thing
about how well these people are doing this or that based on getting
money. It's like you're projecting what you think you're capable
of, not these guys. That's how I look at >> So, here's
where I want to meet Pisco.
That's insane.
So then IRA's got no problem with any of the money in politics
then, right? He just thinks like you like there's no reason to
disclose anything. Like actually we should get rid of all individual
contribution limits. Why are those even there? Do we really believe
that politicians would run for office just to get money for their
campaigns? Just to like build up some structure like this where
they could, you know, sell influence, petty pedal influence to
people. Do we really believe that? Why do we have any disclosures?
Why do we have any financial limits in politics? It seems like
they're just all guys, most people are honorable, right? >> Soy
pill like a little bit halfway and then push back at the same
time. So like I think the reason why the general practice to
what Pisco and and Soy Pill were saying should be to disclose
is to avoid situations like this. Like why are we even having
a conversation about this right now? The second part about this
though is that to be clear there was never any established deliverables.
Now a lot of people are having a difficult >> There are
established obligations though. Pis Pisco did not say deliverables.
He said obligations.
And there are obligations.
Right. There are ah I really hate that. I don't care if they
pay for content or not. If I'm paying you to attend mandatory
meetings,
about an hour and a half of mandatory meetings a week where I'm
just updating you on what my thoughts are, my exact political
positions, right? Giving you all the best reasons to have my
political positions and I'm paying you for that. I you should
have to disclose that. You're taking you're taking money from
somebody with an interest who is trying to educate you in a certain
direction in a way that like influences your content because
you're a political creator, right? That should be disclosed.
That should be disclosed unless those obligations are lifted.
That should absolutely be disclosed. I'm >> Wrapping their
minds around that and there's a lot of like conspiracy brain
analysis going on in certain spaces about like we'll put two
and two together. What do you you know what do you think they
were given that money for? They explicitly describe
Pisco is realizing he's got to correct a lot of Pisco is like
oh my co-hosts are going to go on panels on this and uh they're
going to embarrass themselves. I got to I got to educate these
guys real
>> They simply pay them $8,000 a month for the honor of
mentoring them. This is a thing that is true. I think Shredder,
you're being a little a little
I think there could be some element of that where they think
they are paying people to like
create like uh you know like uh how do I put it? They are trying
to create people who push like their kind of talking points,
their thoughts in the world more effectively, right? That's what
the benefit is. It's not just like charitable, oh we're uplifting
creators, right? They're trying to uplift a specific kind of
creator. And I would say that their kind of creator based on
who they're paying probably pretty closely resembles the Democratic
Party. Now, you could go that's a total coincidence. You can't
prove that we're actually affiliated with the Dems or care about
the Dems at all. I don't whatever. Okay. But yeah, the idea that
it's just like, yeah, we're we're just trying to teach these
guys how to just need to tell them how to do their lighting,
okay? And that'll be good for democracy.
If that's how you feel, JTO, that reminds me. I have this awesome
product called Herbal Life I meant to tell you about. Okay. I
feel like um Oh man, it's so funny that you're going the MLM
direction straight raid cuz somebody I talk to a lot about politics
actually has been has been telling me this too and I push back
against them. Like I don't think it's quite like an MLM. I don't
think it's quite like an MLM. Okay. But maybe it is. Maybe I'm
just coping. I don't know >> the program is for it's essentially
like a scholarship program. the whole point of it was mutual
binding though. I I'm not trying to say that there was a deliverable
expectations in terms of specific content. I think that you're
correct about that and I think even Taylor acknowledged that.
So I think that's what you're referring to Hutch and so I'm not
but I just want to be clear about what I mean which is basically
they're promising to use the chorus news what network they're
you binding themselves in a formal contractual way. That's all
I mean by that that there there are some restrictions in their
conduct that is formalized in in a contract and there are mutual
expectations and they're promising their mutual promise. I the
best part of this is the reporting in the article is literally
it seems like the contracts say this based on contracts we reviewed.
It says this. It doesn't even say that these things have been
enforced in the article. Right. Okay. Cherry was telling me that
she feels like it's an MLM. Someone I talked to Cherry was telling
me that she thinks it's kind of like an MLM. She had a lot of
comparisons. She wasn't just saying, "I think it's an MLM and
nothing else." She had a lot of like complex reasons that I probably
would have a hard time duplicating on stream right now. Okay.
Um, now I don't have I don't doubt that they happen to be in
ideological alignment to be honest. These creators probably are
mostly happy to tow the party line already, but that only makes
the defensiveness from them weirder. Yeah. I don't Yeah, that's
exactly right. They're just paying people who they think agree
with them and trying to uplift those people. But then when you
say they're not being paid to push the party line, it's like,
well, they are also giving them talking points that push them
I I would assume closer to the party line, right?
If all of these people, if Brian Tyler Cohen and and Luke Beasley
and David Pacman and a bunch of these guys all have the same
opinion, I don't talk about Israel because I think that's bad
for my channel. I think it's a contentious topic and I don't
really want to step. Are they not going to Is that not going
to rub off on any of these smaller creators at all? Is that gonna
is that not going to rub off?
Right. Who's Cherry? Shut up, Zezy. Okay. Contractual obligations.
Yes. Sorry. This is all just to say that the training program
is where things get like a little dicey for me here. When you
pretend when you pretend that there's like nothing there, that
it's like nothing
>> to be bound, which isn't the same kind of dynamic and
just a one-off donation. That's all I mean. I know what you're
referencing is it's >> it's uh obligations and the claims
in the article about the contract. And it doesn't seem like anybody's
disputing the contract the claims about the contracts. It's >> not
a one for one editorial control one for one uh you know money
for content. Agreed. But but that's all I meant. >> In
in practice though there was never this in practice though argument
is so stupid. These contracts have not been signed for more than
like a month or a month and a half, right? Saying in practice
we haven't done this. It's like if you have a bunch of crazy
stipulations in your contracts that you in practice don't use,
but the second I say something that is actually what if I just
Brian Tyler Conn's wife and then suddenly they're like, "Oh yeah,
you actually did a collab that you didn't tell us about. We're
terminating your contract." There's no clause that I can't Brian
Tyler Conn's wife, but there's a clause that says I can't do
collabs without their permission. So maybe one time I didn't
get their permission, now they fired me. So, if it's not a part
of that, if they're not trying to restrain that conduct, which
is doing collabs without their permission, they're not trying
to restrain people in how they disclose their partnership with
with Chorus,
then remove it from the contract. It's that simple. Don't keep
clauses there that you say aren't representative of your
like a single, >> if I can't Brian Tyler Cohen's wife and
get away with it because of those contracts, then those contracts
are Wait, hold on. Internet Ray,
buy me any articulation of this from somewhere. They need it
there for liability to keep their 501c4 status. So I guess the
parts about which politicians I So if that's true and they need
them there, then I'm guessing that those are going to be enforced
at some point, which means there are actual restrictions on conduct
that will come up, right? Like there must be some point where
if they're if they're advocating against certain politicians
enough, they need to pull that back with their like sponsor creators
or else what is the point of those clauses being there? That
is a point. the point Pisco made. Wait, when did he make that
point? I haven't watched a lot of Pisco content. There's no way
he just said that now. I didn't miss that just now, did I? I
don't think he just made that point. >> There's like deliverables.
So, like if if this group uh hired these or or brought onboarded
these smaller creators into the program and then, you know, gave
them instructions about like what topics to cover and these sorts
of things. You're in that in that uh >> to their obligations
not deliverables.
That's not what we just said.
you these are different points. >> So you would be legally
obligated to disclose in this particular arrangement. There is
no legal obligation. Now that being said, like I said, I think
it probably should if I was in the program, I think I probably
would have said something. And to be clear, it doesn't look like
there. >> Not would you should you not would you should
people disclose. >> Well, yeah. I mean, that's why we're
having this conversation. I mean I I I can see kind of both angles
of >> commit like there's no um like I think I think you're
correct to point that the general best practice would be to disclose
just to avoid this kind of conversation. However, obviously people
are taking the story and and going in
>> Oh, yeah. No, no, no. It's fine. It's fine, Cherry.
Um, you're basically saying that like even if you Yeah. Even
if you don't enforce these these parts of the contract, right?
People will follow them naturally because they're rules that
they think are going to be enforced. So, you'll have like a group
of people, maybe 80% of people won't even like buff it up against
these in any way. They'll just they'll just say, "Oh, that's
the rules. I'll check with them every time.
unfounded directions like it's really ma like it's a really mainstream
narrative and I don't even have to name any names but pool of
creators in the space that have collective millions of audience
uh audience members are theorizing that these people were paid
to be silent about Israel Gaza and push the party
>> Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on. I need to see >> the
audience uh audience. >> Oh, so a bunch of creators are
taking Imagine being upset about this, guys. Imagine there's
a bunch of creators with millions of people in their audience
who are totally misleading us with the with this article. They're
taking the article way out of context and they're lying about
it to malign somebody or some
Wow. It's almost like there's two different groups doing that
same process. Their side gay and bad. Okay. My side based in
awesome >> audience members are theorizing that these people
were paid to be silent about Israel Gaza and push the party line
and there's no evidence for this whatsoever. So that's something
maybe we can unpack a little bit more. IRI, you wanted to continue
there. >> Well, so I don't think that they were paid okay.
I don't think that they were paid to avoid talking about Israel.
But also the idea that one creator criticizing Israel or sorry
one creator criticizing yeah criticizing Israel criticizing Israel
Israel policy before the contracts were signed. The idea that
that disproves that they only only support creators or they they
prevent, you know, they don't prevent criticism of Israel. I
don't think you've proven that at all. I don't think there's
like any proof. I don't think it's been proven. I don't allege
it, but like it's weird when I don't allege something or I don't
think it's reasonable to allege something and people go, "Yeah,
that's totally debunked." Right? The idea that they're not getting
paid to to be soft on Israel at all or that the idea that they're
getting paid to be soft on Israel is debunked. It's like, "No,
I can tell it's not debunked." But like, why are you even saying
it? It's not a reasonable It's like Legal Mindset. Okay. Legal
Mindset a couple months back. Remember when that guy accused
me of being a and legal mindset did like a video disproving it
that disproved [__] nothing? And I'm just like, dude,
you've actually made me curious about like your entire thought
process and like I think you're kind of sus suspicious now cuz
you just said you debunked this allegation and it was a totally
bad allegation. It was a nonsense allegation. But the way you
said it was debunked like I we can all tell that everyone knows
you didn't debunk. You just like he just served me up a plate
of [__] We're like this is uh these are brownies.
Like no they're not. Why are you doing this? I don't don't do
that. What are you doing? Why are you trying to fool me? >> I
I'm just building on what you're saying. I don't think these
people that are being critical of the chorus group care at all.
I think they're just using it as something to to push a a false
narrative. But where do you draw the line? What if you're banging
somebody who's of the a different political
uh leaning, right? What if I'm banging a conservative? Do I have
to reveal that to you guys? Cuz maybe I'm not being as harsh
on MAGA. >> So, I can tell you what Pisco's argument >> Yeah,
if you're doing like a long-term girlfriend arrangement or something
with like a Republican influencer and they are they're doing
that in exchange for some political benefit, some political content,
something like that, then yeah, if they were like hoarding themselves
to you so you would like let them on their STR, yeah, you should
disclose that >> Yeah, because I'm banging some hot magga
chick now. I mean, where do you draw the line on this? This is
a funny funny example, but I unironically think that if you have
a message and an idea that every time you're talking about how
MAGA is this like baseless immoral movement and then it comes
out that you've been keeping secret that you associate deeply
with a specific MAGA person and are okay >> this is a really
crazy hypothetical for soy to come up with. Okay, >> in
the context of him defending Destiny so hard on those child comments
like a couple weeks ago. This is very bizarre >> that and
it goes against kind of what your values are. Yeah, I would think
that would be a similar thing in the same way that a lot of these
left and and lib left people probably say they want money out
of politics and this if you don't really look too deep on what
is actually happening. You just see, oh, they had money in politics
here, they're getting paid to say things looks a lot worse. And
I'm just saying if you knew a creator who was like a well-known
atheist,
far-left creator, and they suddenly became both very soft on
conservatives and a and explored Christianity at the same time
while secretly carrying out a relationship with somebody who
is super faright and a Christian. I'm I'm just saying you might
have some concerns about that person's ethics. Okay? You might
have some concerns after the fact. >> That's why I do think
the article is a lot more misleading than people are are letting
on because that's not really what's happening. It's not like
it's like ah here's here's 10 grand kid now go now go say Biden's
cool and hip you know like that's not what was going on. It was
hey we want to promote these creators we're going to give you
money to you know establish yourself more. Now the only thing
that I have seen um is there was like hey if you're going to
interact with or comment on a politician or topic using our money
specifically
run it by us first. Not you can't do it, just hey, if I'm going
to give you 10 grand
because I'm trying to promote left-wing creators and then out
of nowhere, you use my 10 grand to go do like some tour where
you talk [__] about every single DNC and say they're
all awful and subvert exactly the reason >> and that could
be campaign finance related uh compliance, too. So, I%
100% is. Yeah. >> Okay. Doesn't that like literally mean
isn't that literally saying they would have to compel your speech?
you they would have to control your speech
in those cases. Like I can see what's going on here. Okay. You
basically never disclose to them that you're actually using the
money for that, right? And you're fine. But they need the they
need the rules in there to say and they can't quite say exactly
that, right? But it is you need the rules in there to say, "Hey,
if you're going to criticize a certain politician, you need to
tell us like you need to tell us if you're using our money cuz
then that would be bad, right?" But the idea would be money's
funible.
Never tell us that you can do the whatever you want with the
money. Just don't tell us. We don't actually care. But they can't
say that because then that is a campaign finance >> because
these are non-t taxable entities. And so electioneering communications,
there's restrictions on specific electioneering communicate.
That doesn't mean any ideological communication. I see some confusion
there. So, so I think some of these contractual provisions range
from being characterized completely wrongly in the sense that
like they're there for compliance purposes or being, you know,
subject to the the direct usage of the funds, which I think is
totally fine. and everyone understands the brand and reputational
risk associated with like you know your funds being used in a
way in a smear ad something that the course is like not opposed
to and then or being like totally misconstrued
you know in the case of the disclosure provision. So, so I agreed
with you on the characterization uh characterization there, but
I do want to address what I said head on, which is this kind
of like where does it end the disclosure stuff. Uh I think that
there are absolutely some personal relationships perhaps that
um in context would be the kind of thing that you should disclose
for sure. Um if you take a certain position for example like
let's say that you take a position that you know all um illegal
immigrants should be deported and then all of a sudden you know
this oh no we're we're fast approaching the Richard Spencer hypothetical
guys at what point is it totally unethical for Richard Spencer
to carry on his relationship with his Asian wife okay while also
claiming to be a white supremacist? At what point can we no longer
take Richard Spencer
Okay, I trusted this mother.
>> You're having anal immigrant or or you're one of these
people who like um is against gay people and think that gay marriage
should be outlawed and you know you're not disclosing the fact
that you in fact are having a gay person and you are gay yourself.
I I think that there are certain situations, you know, I can't
define them all in which maybe disclosure would make sense. But
just because I I can't put a a fine line on where exactly the
disclosure is required, but that but that's making the perfect
the enemy of the good and saying just because I can't define
the contours perfectly around what should be disclosed that therefore
we should never have any disclosure ever. And I think that when
we're dealing with this kind of thing, money, the exchange of
money, that is like in the core of what people expect for disclosure.
They despect it for far when it's like some uh you know foreign
money coming in at bare minimum and I think a social norm for
money changing hands in political commentary domestically that
should be expected. >> Well again I just what does it do
though like and again I think soy pill pointed out a great point
that it's up to 8,000. I guarantee there's three people out of
90 that are getting 8,000. The rest of them are getting 1,200
bucks a month. People are acting like this is gamechanging money
for most of the creators. It's probably not. And so, you know,
they're just getting a little bit of help to show up and get
some instructions on how to post stuff and some ideas and, you
know, how to set up an LLC. Like, I don't know, man. To me, it's
like it's >> I don't know, man. It seems like they're just
getting like, you know, a couple thousand bucks and being told
how to turn their ring light on. Okay. I don't really think there's
anything else going on here. I think it's like basically just
that. So, there like are these I think I would say I'm being
added to this fellowship. I'm getting paid. They're not only
are they teaching me stuff about um about setting up my channel,
being more effective with my channel, but also they're providing
me, you know, I have some compelled some mandatory attendance
education sessions with them. You could almost call it, you could
almost call it, you know, what's what what would be a word for
education that you're mandated to attend? Could that be called
re-educ re-education? Sorry, I'm I'm like doing the Ethan base
while I do it and you guys can't see it. though
re-education. Hassan, would that be re >> It's just like
going to some sort of business school for a little bit or >> So,
no disclosure ever. You don't think that there should be a social
norm of >> It's just guys, it's just like going to business
school. Okay. They're paying for you to go to business school
out of the good of their hearts, >> no matter how much
money in any
>> I'm just trying to think of the positives. Like, is
it going to make anyone feel better about the situation if you
disclose this? I don't know. Like I saw what happened with Progressive
Victory when I was involved in that and people just went insane
thinking the worst things ever and it it did nothing of value
if you disclosed or didn't >> Well, in in some cases like
with Progressive Victory there were there were some like disclosures
that people should have been doing. But like you're right about
the conspiracy stuff. Like I get people in my mentions now like
every day by the dozens that are accusing me of being paid by
Destiny. They're calling it the Destiny pack. So, they're theorizing
the whole >> I mean, objectively, Brianna Woo paid like
a bunch of Destiny's friends to try to be her friends because
she wanted to be friends in in that circle. Like, I'm sorry,
it literally was them paying Destiny's friends. I don't think
it's a slush fund, but they legitimately were just paying Destiny's
friends to be in this thing. Like, I I don't know why we pretend
otherwise. Come on, man. I I I don't think it was uh I don't
think a lot of that was unethical, right? But like even in administrative
positions, even in positions that weren't for influencers, they'd
hired some of his friends, right? Let's just be real. >> thing
was funded by Destiny and that it was like a Zionist operation.
So they're saying that we were paid by Destiny to do Israeli
propaganda, which progressive victory had nothing to do with
Israel and they collaborated with Destiny I think twice on canvasing
events. Like he >> Okay. The fact that there are people
out there doesn't mean that you shouldn't disclose,
right? It's like arguing.
This is the pirate software argument. Okay. Somebody told me
that they were going to kill me. So, I think if you criticize
me for my manage play, you're actually trying to get me killed.
No,
how about you take the like the half of a half of a percent of
total morons
who comment on your [__] and you ignore them and
you deal with like actual substantial criticism. How about that
instead? How about we pretend that those people don't exist?
I'd rather do that. That'd be >> wasn't like funding the
whole operation. Um, that was their logic was like they didn't
want to like force >> I don't think Pey would do October
7th. It's like Brianna Woo was Brianna Woo was supposed to be
responsible for that section of the wall. For some reason, her
voice failed her that day. She couldn't warn anybody to disclose.
if you have some small creator, you know, we all saw like the
backlash to this and the conspiracy theories that went wild based
on absolutely nothing. So, I mean, I'm sympathetic to the argument
that like because they're not legally required to disclose because
there are no deliverables. Then I'm sympathetic to the idea of
like protecting smaller creators as being a part of this thing.
It kind of makes sense like they're going after them like really
hard right now. Um, >> and I I just want to add that when
when creators start making enough money that this stuff seems
like it has any impact, then I'll start making noise about, hey,
we should disclose this or that. But most creators are barely
making it barely surviving. So, I just like I
>> just to be clear, that is when it will have way more
of an impact. Huh. The whole point is if it's like half of your
income, you're way more likely to change the the coverage you
do or change the tone of your coverage to keep the sponsorship.
What are we talking about, bro? Yeah, if these people are barely
surviving, they need their sponsorship to like keep their channel
going. They're going to do whatever they can to keep it going,
right? To keep to keep that uh keep the money coming their way.
I will say that that might be a benefit of course, though, in
that I think it's a six-month program. I don't know if you can
even reenroll.
So maybe the set time limit actually offsets some of those problems
>> that they're not going to have their views changed by
some some organization trying to give them a little help with
the business side of things. I mean maybe I'm naive. I don't
know. But it's just like to me people need all the help they
can get. Why are we trying to put rules on it? >> If they're
so small that this money could be the make or break between whether
or not they're able to make more content. Don't you think that
would give them more of a incentive to a >> I do I do see
Pisco sitting there and he's like he's like grimacing a lot of
the time like
uh I'm going to I'm going to go argue with like uh Aaron at some
point again and she's going to he's just seeing that like what
what Aaron would say to all of these people. I think I think
that's what he's saying right now straight right. He's just when
I see him grimace he's like ah
ah these people get eviscerated >> agree with whoever is
giving the money rather than the people who don't need it. Right?
Like I think the the problem is when it's like hey you're an
independent creator and it's like hey I'll give you this money
just don't say this thing. I'm not saying this is what happened
but this is what people are worried about especially for the
smaller creators because the smaller creators are the one who
>> man's in a room full of morons. No I don't think so.
Ira is not a [__]
Kyra knows exactly what he's arguing for, what he's doing most
of the time. Ira is not an idiot. He's just like an open unrepentant
shill, right? He doesn't care. He You think he's like just being
serious. Ira is not telling you the truth. He is telling you
the most effective thing he can. He's like Dan, but he doesn't
even say he's like Dan. He's not telling you he's lying, right?
He's trying to be effective, the most effective he could be.
Like, it's it's not it's not that he's uh he doesn't actually
believe that financial incentives and, you know, perverse incentives
don't exist. That's not what I thinks, right? That would be insane.
>> Who have more, you know,
>> There's the there's the appearance of that kind of impropriety
being possible. But that but that should lead people to think
like, okay, well, we have the names of what was it like I don't
know 12 to 15 people that were either named in the article or
came out afterwards. Like there's plenty of content on their
feeds to sort of browse through. Is there any evidence that these
people were, you know, like uh super pro Palestinian or were
sounding the alarm about Gaza and then they joined this program
and then that stopped? Like was there is there any actual evidence
that they were swayed in one >> No, but that wasn't said
in the article. That's not said in the article. Why are you contending
with like what Hassan says? Isn't Hassan a >> one direction
or another? Like no. The one thing they keep throwing around
Hutch is like uh what's her name? Oliviana or whatever said Alyssa
Slotkin is cool. She's one of my favorite Democrats. And it's
like >> I can like maybe you could purport that that is
the reason why she said that. But in my experience, hey, when
you hang out with a lot of really, you know, involved people
and you get to know them and they talk to you on a personal level
and explain their politics, it's like, oh, I like this. >> Hold
on, wait, wait, hold on. I want to jump in. This is B. This is
like echo like social media echo chamber. the idea that somebody
can't organically like listen I'm agreeing I'm saying it's stupid
I thought you were letting that I'm saying like look it's like
I I say that I like Roana now and that's not as organic as like
yeah I just read his platform on Wikipedia I got the opportunity
to go along with his campaign and see the inner workings and
talk to him on a one-on-one basis and I'm like yeah I think this
guy's got his finger on the pulse I like his politics but the
exact same thing could happen for an Alyssa Slutkin when someone
like Oliviana or whatever I forgot how to pronounce her is hanging
out with the Biden and going to the White House and it's like
yeah like of course she's going to start liking these people
more. So like it's not like they're paying her to say Alyssa
Slotkin is cool. Like I think that's kind of absurd.
>> Sorry. Go ahead. >> Just to answer your question,
Pisco. If you're being sponsored by a campaign or by an organization
to promote their message, yes, you should disclose that. But
if you're just getting paid to get help with your content, >> I
I don't I don't think you need to tell everybody that. >> Interesting.
So >> that's not the only thing that happens. Hopefully
Pisco knows some of the other obligations. That'd be very helpful.
>> So it's not if there's sponsored content, whether it's
organizational or whether it's related to a campaign. Um so it's
the link between the specific content and what you're
as a product and the deliverable. That's where the disclosure.
>> You're legally obligated to in that spot. If there's
any kind of deliverable, you have you have to disclose that.
I'm >> I'm not sure about that. Like I know that there's
like consumer financial
>> Yeah, it's the it's the uh federal consu It's the f
which one is it? It's a consumer viewer one, right? >> You
have disclosures and you have to put like ads and [__]
But, you know, I don't know how much I can stretch this guys.
Like, if I'm getting paid for like an an influencer
like in >> uh $10 donation, how would the stipen from chorus
be any more influential than the money the creators get from
their audience? Feels like the audience captures a bigger indicator
of content leaning most of the time. Uh Pisc's already answered
this for anybody who's not a complete [__]
In one case, you sign a contract with obligations. In the other
case, there is no obligation.
>> Like if I'm getting >> if they're going to argue
that soft power, soft pushes in a direction are indicative of
like how you'll influence somebody. You want to argue that audience
captures a bigger deal, then we can argue about the soft pushes
that come from that contract, from the mandatory education sessions.
Okay. We can talk about all of that. Yes. >> Paid for like
an an influencer
like incubator by
Daily Wire and they're paying me $8,000 a month to give and I
have that financial relationship. I think again I'm not saying
there's some legal imposition. I'm not even saying we should
get all bent out of shape about it and like not support Chorus
anymore because of this mistake. I think it is a mistake. Um
I'm just saying like I think I should disclose that, man. I mean,
that's a lot of money and I think that the audience has a right
to know. Um, and then when I say right to know, I mean legal
right to know, but that it's good for for lib content creators
and for for us generally in the in the media um space to to be
upfront about that stuff and and then people can like judge for
themselves whether they trust, you know, IRI or Pisco or Hutch
uh given that financial relationship. But it's it's the same
kind of sh that we would like when we look at the >> uh
you could say this Sherry, but we've seen we've seen IRI and
who he raids his is like raid selection. We've seen the comments
he made about We've seen comments he's made, okay? We've seen
that he's got a sub in like every single EAL's channel on Twitch.
You can't really make the argument that it's Hutch. Okay, I'm
sorry. It's just not there. The evidence is there. It's in >> the
Trump administration. >> They fly for a white guy. >> Do
you trust Trump to be impartial when he gets the Qatari airplane
or when he when all these people are sending him uh basically
legalized bribe to the the crypto stuff in some cases illegal
stuff? No. I mean, we all understand that money is a little different
and and and how money influences people that there's a potential
for for bias there. And I'm totally fine saying that there should
be a social norm in in disclosing that if it bears on content
at all or relates to content at all. I can't define the exact
scope of of when that turns into a mandated disclosure ethically.
But I just think that there's some uh duty there. >> But
but Pisco, you maybe buried the lead a bit a little bit there
by saying it was a mistake. What didn't they disclose? Did they
not disclose their part of Chorus? Did Chorus not say they give
a stipen? Like >> I I don't know. >> Didn't disclose
the financial relationship, which is the thing. The the financial
relationship with obligations is what was not disclosed. Partnership
with Chorus, which was nebulous, never defined, was disclosed,
but partnership with Chorus was disclosed, but it was it meant
nothing, right? The the organization had just started. And I
I reject the idea that these people say, "Well, I've partnered
with Chorus before Chorus was offering any money." And then they
say that was me disclosing that uh everything I needed to. Yeah,
I think that's just really is live. If you want to argue, I don't
think Rey has looked into this very much. Unless he's been looking
into this in his off time. I think he's been moving or doing
something. Right. Streaming with Darius >> no freeze crater.
I think that they disclose that they're associated with chorus.
And to the extent that Taylor is accusing them of not doing so
and just generally secretive, I think that is a distortion and
that's wrong and that's and that's part of this what I take to
be the disingenuous uh attack on chorus. So I think they were
disclosing the relationship with the entity, but of course that's
not a disclosure of financial compensation or or you know some
kind of award and and so I do think that there's an additional
obligation specifically to disclose that you're making money
and and there might have even I haven't seen a denial of this
contractual language to the effect of you're not allowed to disclose
that you're part of the program or getting money. Um again not
the same thing as being uh forbidden from being told about the
association or sorry from telling about the association with
course. >> He's with Darius again. I think Darius is in
Arizona or something. I think they're hanging out if I'm not
mistaken. Maybe I'm wrong, but I think so. I feel this way too
straight raid. And I think that I think that the response to
the article makes me lean in this direction. If it was a mistake,
I think they would have just gone, "Oh, that was a mistake. We're
going to change it." I think the response to the article has
been overwhelming because I don't think they want to change it.
I don't think that >> itself. But I do think that there
>> I I can't prove that. But I don't I think it was intentional.
I think they do want the appearance of like organic lock step
messaging from like everybody that it's just like obvious what
we think is true. I think that's what they're going for. I don't
think they're going to get it now because of the >> Again,
I don't want to spend so much time focusing on it because I think
that this should be an easy thing to agree on. Um maybe not that
you should disclose that you're getting paid additionally to
the associational relationship. Well, let's let's dive into the
particulars
of the the article that that we take issue. >> I knew I
knew Listen, I'm listening to Pisco Talk. I knew I was like 95%
overlap with Pisco and like the exact the exact prescription,
the exact like response to this. I just think I think he doesn't
see the narrativization from his side as bad and I see it as
like equally bad to Taylor Loren stuff. But I think on like what
to actually do with chorus and how to make it like proper and
and all good going forward. I think I'm basically on the same
page as him. Uh we'll see if he gives any other opinions that
are off here. But >> with uh I I'll kick off like the most
egregious thing in that article >> for me was actually
in the subheading. Um in the subheading she said essentially
that these creators were paid to tow the party line. Like that
was the thing that I felt was the most disingenuous and malicious
aspect of that reporting because you know she might say she was
looking at the
>> So I would love to know for the record can we get Taylor
Loren's on the record did she write the title and by line of
the article?
I feel like if she hadn't, she probably would have said so, right?
Like I think so, from my understanding, sometimes the I think
titles are always the editor, but the by line is is like uh could
go either way.
And so if the if the by line is what she's getting blamed for
is Wired's by line, I think you I think there's a big reason
they all attack Taylor Loren, there's a huge huge set of things
you could point to with Taylor Loren where you can attack her
reputation. She gives her her reputation as a weapon, right?
But not the same with Wired.
Not quite the same. Okay. Fact, you know, she reached out to
v various creators and I don't think any of them agreed to speak
with her before this. Now, she had written an article previously
and some of these creators had expressed
um kind of shock with the way that she was framing things before.
Um, so I'm I'm really not really sure why they didn't want to
speak with her or give her any kind of comment, but if she would
have looked into like I know >> that's the other thing.
Chorus was reached out to for comment. Every creator
referenced in the article was reached out to for comment. Why
did none of these people go, "Whoa, that's weird. Whoa, that's
weird. Why'd you do that? Why'd you say that?" >> No, there's
like 90 creators, but it's like your job. If she would have like
looked into these creators feeds, she would have seen that there
were many of these creators were not keeping it a secret. And
there were plenty of creators that were speaking out against
the Democratic Party and uh um Israel specifically. There was
one creator where it was like so intense. Like there was one
creator, I can't remember her name, but she was featured on the
page >> Yeah, she was featured on their website and she
basically was like calling the Democratic party like complicit
in genocide. Are there people, just to be clear, are there people
in the Democratic party who accuse like actual Congress people
who accuse the Democratic party of genocide,
being complicit in genocide?
Cuz I could have sworn like a Rashida Talib, like some of these
people, they probably say something along these lines. No, I
would have thought so. I don't think having one or two outlier
candidates is necessarily like dispositive of you being Democrat
aligned. I just think that's silly. Rashida Taliban. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I just think it's it's silly to say we have one or two
of these people. And also, I don't know if those videos came
before or after these contracts could have been offered, right?
But we have one of one or two of these people out of like 80
creators in the cohort. And you know what? Uh that's just positive.
That that proves that we don't do that. No, it doesn't. What's
going to happen to that one person who's got those more extreme
opinions when they're hanging out with all of these creators?
They're networking with all these creators. They go to the messaging
check-ins with all these creators. They go to the the what do
you call it? the advocacy trainings with all these creators,
right? I think eventually that creator who's kind of out there
is going to slowly moderate. No. And if this was >> we
not see like an AOC like effect on them or is really a program
that was meant to incentivize people with a wink wink nudge nudge
to just like push the party line. There is no explainable, no
plausible reason why someone like her would have been not only
in the program, but as Soy Pill said, her her face was on the
website, like she was featured on the website. I'm curious, what
were some of your um problems with the article uh everybody on
the panel? Well, I think just in principle it seems like the
narrative that people are taking away from it is like you said
something that's not true, which is people were being paid to
say things that they wouldn't otherwise say or being tailored
in their content and restricted in ways that would otherwise
kind of suggest impropriy. And I have yet to see evidence of
that. I have yet to see this kind of like this person changed
their opinion. This person was not allowed to make content. Again,
um
I don't think there's anything explicit here cuz I think anything
explicit here would be a campaign uh a campaign finance violation.
Like obviously, right? Obvious campaign finance violation if
they're doing anything direct like this. Okay. The thing is
you're pushing all these people in a certain direction. What's
the sweeping like? Are they critiquing course? Uh there's some
critiquing. There's some stuff. Yeah. >> On this um that's
really upset me. I think Taylor has since kind of clarified or
maybe I don't know if you want to call it a walk back but on
Twitter said it's about not saying that you got money from 1630
which is like the fund that paid chorus to then pay who then
paid these uh stipens to these creators but I don't even know
if these creators know anything about 1630. They just know they
signed up with chorus to make stuff. So it's like why why do
they have to then look at who's funding the nonprofit? Like why
do like that that that part to me is just like not on the creators
at all. If you want to criticize Chorus for not disclosing that,
maybe. But like, yeah, I just don't see like what the ultimate
like thing anyone is really supposed to be mad about considering
there's so many programs like this. Um, and as far as I can tell,
no one is >> again, it's the lack of disclosures. It's
the explicit contract language preventing disclosures, right?
And and then the the slide saying here are the pre-approved ways
to disclose anything to do with us, right? That's that's what's
going on. is saying any lies or or or tailoring their message.
But it does seem like it's part of this narrative of, hey, the
Democratic party lost 2024 because they wouldn't be critical
of Gaza. They don't have their finger on the pulse. They don't
know how to do influencer ground game. They're struggling now
to find the Joe Rogan of the left. They're spending $20 million
to like reach out to young men. And this is just another story
that fits into that narrative of and they're dumping all this
money in to secretly fund creators to say what they want to spread
their message cuz they're not authentic. And that's why I think
it's resonating with the Taylor Loren and Hassan crowd, but it
doesn't really fit. I don't think it's checks out. I think it's
just >> I mean, I think that's
broadly true. I think I think there are some assertions from
the Taylor Loren's article that I can get behind. I think Taylor
uh went on Glen Greenwald and one of the things I didn't disagree
with was I do think this is like sort of top down control, not
from the Democratic party, but from donors to the Democratic
party, right? It's a It's an attempt at like some top down influencing
that I don't think works and I think I think makes your your
influencers look less authentic.
That's my opinion, right? I think it's just it looks less authentic.
>> Authentic. I just want to react to just one comment
that I'm seeing and from bad enchilada who says Hutch is a [__]
Hold on. What does it say? It keeps going. Hutch is a [__]
Uh god damn it, it keeps moving. He's pointing to someone on
the margins to prove chorus doesn't obviously have an agenda.
Here's the issue with that. If this program was meant to incentivize
people to tow the party line, there is no way that you can explain
her being in this program. And it wasn't just >> Yes, there
is. So that like Hutch can say that 1% of this thing cut against
the other the other 99% proves that the direction of the 99%
is not discernable. Yes, Hutch, that is exactly. They they put
that magnet in there for you explicitly. Thank you. Yes, Hutch.
It was just for you, Hutch. Yes, >> just her. There were
like two or three other creators out of the 12 or 13 that we
know of that were outspoken on Gaza >> that were critical
of the Democratic Party. So, how do you explain that? Like some
I' I've heard some people say, "Oh, it was so they could have
like a token like pro Palestinian person for appearances." But
like >> then what's the point? >> What is the point
of that? But who >> what was the point of counterpoints
being in uh in progressive victory? >> Who are they trying?
>> In fact, I think I think some of this stuff I legitimately
think some of this stuff is a part is about compliance, right?
Like I do think some of it in terms of saying you're apolitical
or nonpartisan. I do think some of it is about compliance >> to
like Yeah. Who are they trying to assuage in terms of >> their
their secret conspiracy goes so deep. It's like we'll we'll have
this agenda that we'll promote. We'll spread it everywhere, but
we'll also spread the complete opposite with some of our top
creators just so no one suspects that we're spreading the opposite
message. It's like, okay, or the more likely explanation is there
weren't restrictions on whether or not you could criticize Gaza.
And a lot of people that I don't think there were restrictions
on whether or not you could criticize Gaza. I'm saying that just
to be clear that that person's like agenda and what they push
for probably like 95% aligns with the Democrat party and them
not supporting Gaza was like not a breaking point. And obviously
it's like well are we going to cut this person out who's like
a big person who's been shilling for us all over the place that
was named by Taylor Lorenz in her article in April. No, not over
her gossip position. No, we're not going to cut her off. Why
would we do that? That they're more willing to give money to
might already align with their message. Like you can call that
manufactured consent, but it just makes sense that more of these
people that are Democrats are just in general going to be less
likely to criticize Democrats when they want to criticize not
only the people that are about to win an election or the people
in power right now. Like I don't know like yeah it's just it's
such a razor does not say oh yeah they have the the secret token
pro Palestine people. It's very strange. I I want to respond
real quick to the the notion of some of the things I disagreed
with. Um but I did see also I'm getting one guy in the chat uh
this comparison to tenant media. I think it's different for several
reasons. One is I I I I think that there um is a very big important
distinction here that the funders the ultimate funders here at
uh turnout being you know Russian government agents which matters
both legally and I think um ethically here. Uh and two I do think
that there's a self-standing obligation on behalf of creators
to um make sure that there's no uh you know that their money
is coming from some legitimate source. In the case of tenant,
you had like Edward Gregorian, you had um evidence that someone
that some of the creators there were like aware of how suspicious
this was and there was a onetoone sort of connection between
this Edward Gregorian figure and themselves and it's not like
1630 fund which has like a Wikipedia page and people know what
it is and it's been you know funding things uh you know generally
in the country you know it's a it's a dark money organization
quote unquote dark money organization but it's generally known
about and I think that uh in terms of due diligence the kind
of um oversightes by someone like Dave Rubin aren't the same
oversightes um or not even oversightes here. Um so so I just
think it's a choice about whether or not categorically you think
that these kinds of organizations are off the table when it comes
to leftwing groups. Um and that and that's one of the things
that I think IRI mentioned certainly I know that Hutch has been
uh waving this flag about is do some of the critics really have
a problem with the setup? Put aside the disclosure. Do you really
have a problem if this was an incubator funded by a 501c4
or where 501c4 money was being channeled through it? If this
was to help anti-genocide pro Gaza leftist creators, would you
have an issue with doing this tit fortat? Especially when the
Supreme Court has signed off on it. I don't think that you would
just because we have Go ahead. Sorry. So go >> a damn thing.
Well, I I I wanted to I wanted to move the conversation towards
a a broader conversation about like dark money and politics like
uh IRI. What do you think about the idea of, you know, right-wing
media organizations that themselves take in tens of millions
of dollars, you know, dark money funding? Uh should the left
like unilaterally disarm on like should we just like close oursel?
It kind of reminds me of the gerrymandering conversation to be
>> Yes. Yeah. >> Exactly. Hell no. >> Well,
I could push back on I could push back on this though. The idea
is not well let let talk. He hasn't spoken in a little bit. Yeah.
Yeah. I >> I just say we should take all the money we can
get. I trust my fellow content creators. They will not be persuaded
by money to change their opinions. I I know these people. I've
gotten to know a lot of them. And it there's just this like weird
idea that people will just change their mind for a few >> Dude.
Okay. Um let me see here.
Not sure what I want to do. Out of time for a little bit. Yeah,
Pisco's watching. He's not not loving it. Uh, man, man, you guys
are pretty crazy. >> $8,000 a month, which is absurd. It
tells me more about Taylor than anybody else. I don't know. You
know, I know content creators and I could give them
a month and they're not going to change their opinion on anything.
>> I just I don't know who believes this. Who believes
this? Who Who believes this? I don't know if IRI realizes this,
but when you give answers this stupid,
you actually like convince people things are going wrong. like
you are lying. Like you are actually making me more suspicious.
It's like I'm I'm talking about how you know we got like a bodybuilding
podcast. All right. And IRI comes on. Okay. We got a b it's me
me and Soy pill. Okay. We're in this bodybuilding podcast and
IRI comes on and just says, "Yeah, I hit myself in the in the
balls with a sack full of dimes all the time and it really helps
me get ready for workouts." And it's just like, "Brother, I don't
think that works. You just said something that has you just said
something so stupid, so profoundly stupid with no basis in reality
whatsoever. In fact, it's like seems to be completely uh completely
anti-reality. It's it's just a total fabrication. It's totally
made up. You've just said something so stupid that I now I'm
now suspicious of everything you say. Like, is this guy taking
money from some people? He just came on and he he decided to
roll out the opinion. I don't think people can get compromised
by money. It's just $96,000 a year to be a political influencer.
What could possibly go wrong, bro? Like, I I don't understand.
He's unironically arguing right now that Listen, guys. I think
money doesn't really affect people's opinions. I Okay, then why
wait? I Why do political advertising at all? Why do any of the
guys money can't affect people's opinions? All right. Money money
doesn't buy opinion. Okay? Money doesn't buy any social currency.
Why? Why even do advertising? I don't dude. >> A lot of
a lot of a lot of people would. I I gotta put back in a lot of
people money. That's a full time basically six figure salary
to be clear. I >> Okay, so hopefully everybody being like,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
IRI, you're saying something insane right now.
Hopefully that brings them back to reality. That'll reel them
back in. Right. I'm just saying that people have principles and
people mean what they say when they come on here and create their
content. I know people get upset to hear that, but I believe
that. So, you know, call me naive or whatever you want, but to
the larger point, we should take Listen, when I donate to the
wild Latina and she bends over and writes my name on her whiteboard
and says she loves me and she'll love me forever. Okay? When
I do that, I'm being IRI, by the way. When I do that, she means
it. She would never lie to me. Okay. She would never lie to me
just for money. She means it. That's I by the way. That's I That's
I
Wild Latina fan. Okay. Take all the money. Use all the tools
available to us. Just like gerrymandering. I hate gerrymandering.
I think it's one of the most poisonous things for our democracy.
But boy, do I support gerrymandering the out of California and
New York right now because that's what the right is doing in
Texas. We have to bring a gun to a gunfight. We need to play
the game of dark money and we need to >> That's totally
fine. But that's not what you were just saying. You're just saying
you don't think it affects people. Then you're going, "But we
need to play the game of dark money. Why do you need to play
the game of dark money? Money doesn't affect people's opinions.
I Why Why would you need dark money if money doesn't affect people's
opinions? Shut the [__] up." This is more what he's
actually saying. Okay. which I would just if everybody just said,
"Yeah, we're gonna we're gonna play dirty because uh these guys
are sick and even if we lose some of our principles along the
way, no matter basically no matter how much we have to burn,
we'll be better than Trump." That's how a bunch of these people
think. And I don't even necessarily think that's like totally.
Okay. But then they lie to me about it. They they lie and say
like, "Well, I actually I actually think you could give as much
money to these people as you possibly could and I don't think
it changed their opinion at all." No, that's not what you think,
IRI. If that's not what you think, you're just lying to me right
now. >> Stop attacking each other over it. And if there's
a couple of bad apples in the bunch that do take the money and
change >> Wait, how could there be bad apples? You trust
all of these people. I I
He's walking back his position, but it's just like, why'd you
start saying the stupid thing to begin with? Why couldn't you
just said this from the start?
Now he's walking back his position. And it's like, well, I don't
want to hold that against you, but like this is, by the way,
with this entire thing, that exact kind of response where the
first response is, I think you're too stupid to have this conversation,
so I'm going to lie to you really badly in a such a bad way.
I'm going to lie so poorly to you that it's obvious I think you're
it's like, okay, just literally anything but that is cool to
me. Just don't lie to me so badly that it's clear you think I'm
a [__] [__] Any other option would be
great. Our Ryan Hutch got to be double agents to make the liberals
look worse. Sometimes it seems that way. Sometimes it really
do be like that. >> Their opinion then so be it. But the
vast majority of people will do the right thing, use the money,
amplify their message, and we will benefit from >> Wait,
so two things. One, uh I see someone in chat saying 8,000 a month
is not 600. Oh, sorry. 96,000. Go [__] yourself.
Second, um, this is not necessarily the gerrymandering thing
because we can still do all the funding and still disclose it.
And I think that was one of Taylor's points that I do think is
more salient. It's like, why? Yes, take all the money we can
to fight back against this ridiculous like crazy stuff, but just
say, "Hey, I'm getting a bunch of money to fight back." I think
I think that's not playing the same game, but still using the
resources. You're not disarming, but you're being more transparent
about it. >> Do do you think that So, like, yes or no.
Do you think the left should should take advantage of dark money
funding? >> Yes. I think the goal, >> you know, would
be so much better a conversation and I'm keeping track of these
things. Let's say that your funding your dark money funding is
twice as effective if you don't disclose. Are you going to disclose?
Let's say it's way more effective. If you have the appearance
of or of an organic movement where you guys have a lot of the
same talking points, but it's coming from different people. You
don't disclose and it's more effective that way. Do you still
disclose? Is that principle that important?
Right? Like I think there's way more interesting conversations
you could have here because I think that that's probably why
those agreements are in there because I think when it appears
organic other people like if if I can see that somebody's throwing
up this logo, oh, they're a course sponsor creator, I can just
easily go that's a shill and I can discredit them, right? If
they if they all appear organic, they all appear independent,
then it's much harder to do that, right? So like could that be
a part of dark money? Like could that be a part of this argument?
Well, Republicans don't disclose this kind of stuff. If we disclose,
we put ourselves at a disadvantage.
I think that would be an actual interesting conversation to have,
right? What if
and how far does that go? How many principles are you willing
to sacrifice to match Republicans at whatever? Are is it everything?
Is it you'll do anything they do? Because that would be that's
pretty crazy. I'd love to know where those lines are for most
people because it seems like we have these conversations and
people don't really walk down that tree at all. >> Gold
standard is to do like Kyle Klinsky always talks about this and
I agree with it. He says the gold standard is default ads and
um memberships. I think that is the gold standard. I think that
content creators should strive for that level of independence.
I commend people who are able to do it. You know, I I would love
to do it at some point. By the way, I'm not taking money from
uh any other group. You guys know you'll know about >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Is or is Pisco not taking
money from Josiah?
Is Josiah paying Pisco's salary? Is this a thing? I heard this.
I don't know if it's real. >> Any revenue source related
to my content, but >> I did apply to Chorus. You guys should
too. Apparently, I pay a lot. >> So, to to the extent that
um you're able to do the gold standard, what I take to be the
gold standard. >> Whoa, he's applying Soy Pill's applying
to Chorus. Doesn't he already have a ring light? What the else
could they teach him? Why would he apply to Chorus? He's clearly
already got a ring light. He's got a microphone. He posts to
more than one platform.
What could they give him? >> Nerd. I think you should.
And I think >> he's going to take he's going to take that
really important lighting training, OBS setup training, okay?
Microphone sound chain training. He's going to take that all
from somebody who needs it desperately and couldn't possibly
figure it out. >> Should be we should strive for that.
That said, I don't think that we need to just like not accept
money from these organizations that are willing to fund liber
liberal creators. Not only do I think that we don't need to unilaterally
disarm in that way. I think that we were
actually pays onethird of Pisco's rent. K, but this is such a
meme thing. Is it like they have an agreement for the money or
is he paying oneird of the rent because of a bet or is he paying
one of the rent cuz like he pays Yeah. Like I there's no way
that he was just like I'm going to pay oneird of your rent. I
I don't know what you're saying there. It's memes. Shut the [__]
up. What? Don't Don't meme. I asked a real question. Why you
answering a meme way? I said I heard it and then I was like,
but I don't know if it's true. And then you're like, give me
the meme. What the [__] Asking for this after this
election. I think that we've been pining for more resources to
be funneled into these kind of online spaces. >> Started
it, right? >> Yeah. And and that's why I I tweeted out
that I thought that Brian was uh frankly transparent about that
from the beginning. Um so, you know, I commend him for taking
this effort. I wish they had disclosed. >> Bro, can Josiah
figure out When I was on YouTube, Josiah would send me a bunch
of money all the time. Could Josiah figure out kick? Okay, I
need kick subs from Josiah. Okay, that guy used to come in. He
loves doing that. Okay, he makes infinite money. He loves just
going in and making it rain on every creator. This guy needs
to figure kick out. Okay, >> the specific creators, but
just disclose and move on and let's do it. Pisco, what if this
has a negative impact on people pouring money into the space
because they don't want to be associated with some anti-Gaza
like anything like that? Now all of a sudden you've got people
who are willing to donate tens of millions of dollars that maybe
are hesitant to now. >> Yeah, I just said Josiah I said
when I was on YouTube, Josiah donated to me all the time. Yeah,
he he absolutely he's like super generous. That's why I'm saying
I need him to figure out kick because I know he'd be super generous,
>> but he's just not on kick. If he's on kick, he'd be
super generous again. You >> I I think that this um I'm
going to take the optimistic
tone which you often strike IRI is I think that this is probably
in the end on net better for Chorus. I think that more eyes are
now on Chorus. I think that the response has been quite harsh
against the the article. Um, even if there are, and I think that
there's, you know, one or two salient critiques by by Taylor
in general, I think most of us acknowledge that it's a [__]
hit piece and a lot of it's in bad faith and a lot of it's >> No
nodding coming from these three. What we haven't talked all about
that yet, but but I think in general, people are seeing through
that hip piece angle of it um the disingenuous attacks and are
seeing it for what it is and the facts speak for themselves.
And so I I don't think that it's been like >> Listen guys,
this has been the plan all along, okay? Um, Arerodite had to
make some crazy content to get herself banned. She's going to
figure out, okay, the plight of a white woman will drive some
insane
Indian support engineer to figure out a way to get through the
YouTube system and get her unbanned and then I can follow that
same path. Okay, we we had to get a white woman permit off of
YouTube in the same way. Okay. So that she can figure out the
path, they'll help her along and then we can follow whatever
that path is. Okay. I can feel it. I can feel it. That's a joke.
That's a joke. That's a joke. >> Mortally wounded to the
contrary. I think now now that more people know about it and
now that it's more in, you know, people's minds be more stressful.
>> What about just pe people who want to donate in general?
Maybe they'll be a little more hesitant in the future now because
of all this brew. Haha.
>> I'm not so sure. I think that's overstating the importance
of the very people that were >> people have been sowing
out about the 1630 fund for like 8 years IRI. They've been soing
the out about this thing. They they keep donating the money.
Turns out money does change people's opinions and they're even
willing to take the money if it looks a little bad. That uh are
making these kinds of attacks and I don't think they're going
to be quelled by by these kinds of uh attacks especially if they're
seeing the kind of backlash against it and the rallying around
the flag that a lot of the the libs are doing. And um and so
so I'm not so convinced that this has been a mortal blow on these
kinds of efforts. Um and so I won't go that far and and I think
that the future is bright for lib content creators and we should
continue to encourage that. >> I saw a question in chat
I have to ask it which is and we kind of touched on this but
should we immediately be preemptively disclosing anytime we are
paid or just say yes if anyone asks. >> I don't know why
though that's the dichconomy. I think that you should disclose
non-trivial amounts of money and content streams for which there
is a exchange like some kind of right mutual promise. If there's
a mutual promise for money, not just anytime someone donates,
a mutual promise for money where there's some kind of binding
on on both parties, you should disclose non-trivial amounts that
are related to your content. I don't say you disclose for your
Domino's pizza run or or like if you have a paper route or if
you are, you know, making money doing legal representation on
the side or if you're making money doing other stuff on the side.
I think that you don't need >> I swear to God. I swear
to God if one of these people asks, "I have to go to the bathroom."
If one of these people asks after Pisco makes this very clear
again, if they say, "Well, so do you have to like say where all
your super chatters are from?" If I hear that [__]
come out of somebody's mouth after Pisco stops ranting right
now, I'mma come back and I'm going smash my computer. Okay, not
really cuz I need my computer, but I'm going to come back and
I'm going to be real mad actually. Give me a sec. >> Revenue
stream. But as a social norm, I think it's important to disclose
that >> you don't you don't need to do it like every single
time you go live. But if if you have like a regular community
and you know put like a Discord message, pin a message or something
like that. I had a nightbot command when I was doing PV stuff
like it's just generally I think a good idea to disclose these
kinds of >> There's just like what's legally required.
So we have these guidelines to to tell people you know what is
when is it actually required? In this case it wasn't. Um, you
know, and I think Yeah. Yeah. It's just up to the creator, I
think. Man, I don't think at the end of the day it's a Yeah.
Go ahead. You You bring up a good point though, Hutch. Like,
how do you disclose this to satisfy the masses? Cuz you said
it. I said it on stream a couple times. It's like they're just
going to keep moving the goalpost. Well, you didn't say it x
number of times. You didn't say it before you did this. It's
like, are you going to, you know, I don't even think you could
satisfy people by disclosing it in any way at all. They'd say,
"Oh, you only said it once, or you only had it on your website
where nobody goes." Like, you just can't make these people >> I
want to push back a little bit about on on what you just said,
Pisco, a moment ago where you said, you know, like you don't
you don't think that this is going to have like a lasting impact.
>> Okay. I'm pretty sure if you just put the logo on your
stream as like a widget, that couldn't possibly be criticized,
right? Like technically. technically. Not that that seems reasonable
that you have to put like a sponsorship logo up just because
you're taking some money, but like I the idea that you there's
just no way to do it. You would just make it obvious in every
piece of content you do. There's just like a little thing there,
right? That would just be obvious. The idea that you couldn't
possibly make people happy.
>> you think like, you know, I guess you were saying like
liberal media. >> Sure. Internet ray. Yeah. You'd have
to be careful when endorsing candidates. Sure. because uh yeah
because of the campaigns but I that's why I think this kind of
thing is like strange to be paying people essentially a salary
during this
when they are they are creators who endorse candidates and do
things and they are being sponsored by you. It's like you are
sponsoring them and you're almost making it like oh but this
it seems like this sponsorship is kind of it's kind of outside
the lines completely right
trending in the right direction. I think >> like they've
they've kind of proven and these these contract provisions are
there cuz it seems like whatever they're doing right here is
probably coloring pretty close to outside the lines. >> I
think this did very real damage and like that's what pissed me
off. Um because if you go in Brian's mentions, if you go in Pacman's
mentions, if you look at their YouTube comments, it is a deluge
of conspiracy brain rot. N
>> you said hello and then your mic cut. You were like,
h
>> Is this working?
>> Yeah, it's working. >> Oh, okay. >> Okay.
Okay, dude. Nonsense. Uh >> continuing. I think I'm Yeah,
I'm presenting. uh promulgated in bad faith maliciously
by enormous creators.
Um that's the kind of stuff that doesn't really like go away.
Like I would be shocked if a year from now Ryan wasn't still
seeing comments accusing him of being an Israeli propagandist.
And there's no accountability mechanism for this whatsoever.
Like these people in that space pounced on this story as quickly
as they possibly could. >> I hold on. I don't know if people
pounced on this like that quickly and like spun a narrative.
I feel like I feel like the narrative spinning was on one side.
Maybe I Maybe it's just that I follow these libs, right? I follow
like all these libs. I'm like in this Twitter algorithm. Maybe
I missed Maybe I got their spin way more than everybody
>> cuz I feel like I noticed their spin instantly. You
can tell Hutch is like a white man without looking at him. Like
he's never had a struggle in his life. He's like, "This has been
two days of bad press. It's just It's We're never This is so
much damage. >> We're never coming back from this. It's
over. It's over. >> My life's been difficult for two days.
I don't even work for Chorus. I'm not even part of this." And
it's done. >> He He saw that uh he labeled these people
black pill leftists and he's trying to take the name back. Okay.
He's trying to be
>> Yep. Yep. That's what he's doing >> to push this
narrative that liberal media and liberals in media are all super
corrupt and they all work for the man in the system and they're
all running cover for Israel. They're the like virtuous truth
tellers that are, you know, speaking truth to power and they're
just doing it for the love of the game and all this and it's
in service of >> Yeah. I will say Hutch did have his whole
like addiction struggle. So obviously, but other than that, okay,
other than that >> this narrative and then once we saw
all these responses, >> is it if he's not using anymore,
>> uh, not a struggle for him. He's he's come through solid
>> that were thoroughly refuting some of the central premises
in that article. These people doubled down like they didn't they
didn't incorporate any of the new information into their analysis.
They kept pushing it. I respond or I reacted to >> the
new information into their analysis. the new information that
didn't disprove the factual elements of the article. I'm sorry.
You can't say there are no content restrictions at all. There's
not it's not pushing anything at all and then go look there's
one person who was allowed to criticize Gaza before I believe
before they could have signed the contract. Like they're not
making they're not giving
any dispositive evidence. Like they're giving some evidence that
this might not have been a serious thing, right? But but there
is like they're not disproving anything. This doesn't disprove
anything. You're saying it disproves it. It doesn't. And you
know that if you've ever like argued anything on stream where
he was watching the responses but literally not even paying attention.
He was looking at his own chat. And so they would say stuff like
you know Chorus had no say on what we were saying. Like there
was no influence. we made our own appointments with politicians
and did our own interviews and that we had they had no creative
kind of like input on what we were doing and then he would pause
the video and start talking about how the Democratic party was
paying influencers to push the party line. >> Okay, so
your problem is with Hassan. It's not with Taylor. It's not with
Wired. It's with Hassan. That's fine, but why are you acting
like Wired and Taylor are the problem when it's Hassan's spin
that you don't like? By the way, I do think Taylor's
she's a problem when she goes on Glen Greenwald and and spins
in the same way that Hassan does in some ways. Okay, there are
problems with the way Taylor handled this outside of the article,
but he's like
>> What the did Hassan do? Well, he's saying that Hassan
is basically like not listening to any of those Tik Tockers and
he's just going to keep saying whatever he wants the the narrative
to be, right? >> Okay. Every time I tweet at Hutch, he
doesn't read anything that I say and he just repeats. So, he's
not much different from Hassan.
>> He's not. Yeah. No, he's not. He's Yeah.
>> It's It's actually like the very much the same. His
channel, all Hutch does is cover Hassan.
Uh, >> that's really snarky of him. >> Sounds unhinged.
Sounds like snark. Sounds like he's obsessed and doing weird
things. Is he spinning weird narratives in back rooms about Hassan?
That's kind of weird and obsessed and weird. Okay, >> that's
tremendous
like lasting damage. >> And it hurts more coming from the
multi-millionaire who like I wish I had half that much money.
>> And that mother never been. My hope is and my intuition
is that this will cause more eyes to be seen on chorus and that
um regardless of you know I think that there are real costs imposed
by this kind of coverage no doubt um is that they'll come out
ahead here and that the backlash against the article which has
been fierce um it's not just been the case that we've seen overwhelmingly
negative one response >> what's out >> I'm told that
it's hard to tell by my tone
I I really like Hutch.
I don't know if that's clear, but I'm making it clear now. Okay.
>> Would you say like would you say if you had to like
say any noun you could that describes PC? Hutch. Pch. Hutch.
Hutch. >> You say
>> Listen, I'm thinking about Dota. Okay. Uh, would you
say Hutch is your boy? >> Listen, I know I'm criticizing
him a lot. I know I'm saying he's a total I know I'm saying he's
incapable of like actually listening and integrating thoughts
into his head, but Hutch is my boy. Okay. Hutch is >> I
would not No, Hutch is not my Pisco is my boy. Hutch is my man.
>> Okay. All right. All right. Luther. Okay. I >> I
think there's overwhelmingly negative responses to Taylor as
well. And I think for good reason cuz I think that this is frankly
uh there are a lot of dishonest aspects of the article and and
certainly of the the post article narrative including on uh Taylor's
interview with Glenn Greenwald among other >> that's wild
that she's talking with him too cuz he's like so discredited
like magabrained like anti >> dude why do these why do
these people speak why how is Glenn Greenwald
marained like that's just so stupid to
>> Are you assuming he's not marained because you've seen
him in the >> No.
Um, >> okay. Because he did the whistleblower
>> like he he did the reporting on Edward Snowden. I would
say a lot of populism has some overlap with libertarianism, right?
If you look at the law tubers, a lot of them libertarians,
they support Trump because they think that that is like protecting
my freedoms. >> Yeah. Wouldn't you think? >> Yeah,
you could you could do that, but it's just not manga. It's like
to call it MAGA in my opinion. >> Well, yeah. I think maybe
>> I wouldn't say Glenn is MAGA, but I think because they
associate him with like uh whistleblowing and,
you know, revealing the government's doing to us, spying on us,
>> they're just going to automatically think or associate
it that way. I think I think Glenn sees Trump as an ally because
he sees Trump as anti-establishment, right? But I think as Trump
has become more establishment, I think Glenn is kind of eh backed
away. Glenn like a Russia hoax guy like as in >> But would
you say he's a whistleblower? >> Okay. Okay, dude. Okay,
dude.
So I don't come on
anti like you know proje like totally grifted hard and the fact
on him like so hard I remember I remember specifically their
beef and I took Taylor's side in that beef um and there have
been he has totally the ambassador and so in a very kind of I
think a very slimy way who I don't like and Taylor who I don't
like had her on and I think um Taylor rightly called him out
for his like oh our favorite journalist very valuable abled member
and uh and so yeah, I I think that
>> rightly called him out. >> She did do that. >> She
did call him out. I was just like, okay, like he was kind of
trying to bury the hatchet and like be a little he was trying
to be humble and like >> and she was just kind of like,
"Fuck you, Gwen." >> It was funny. He did the interviewer
[__] where right off the bat, just like Adam Freidland,
whatever that motherfucker's name is, right off the bat, just
trying to be sweet, trying to warm you up
and she's just like, "No, no, we're not >> Very rude in
my opinion. I thought I just felt like it was rude. I felt like
Glenn was standing on French and she slapped it down. Okay, well,
you know, Glenn was just trying to be a nice guy. All right,
nice finish last these days. That's what I hear. >> No,
I understand. I understand why you think that, but they're mad
at her for doing the interview as if she didn't smack down an
olive branch, right? >> Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure,
sure. Ease. I mean, they're mad at her for doing the interview.
They're just mad at her for existing right now. They're mad at
her for everything.
>> Um, it's a little bit slimy, some of these characters,
but I just want to be clear about something. I It's my intuition
that Chorus will come out ahead. It's my hope. I will try to
make it so that um I'm at least spreading the narrative that
that I think is true, which is that, you know, they should have
disclosed, but everything else is uh and and frankly not worth
your time in terms of the disingenuousness. But but yeah, no
uh I I I guess I can't prove that to you, Hutch, but um I recognize
are responsible. >> No, I think so. I think your critique
has been like very fair. I think you have a reasonable take when
it comes to disclosure and I think your analysis so far is has
been uh appropriately
uh critical of Taylor Lawrence but I looked like you wanted to
talk
>> quick second quick checkin
we had some Nick Wickley content tonight what is >> and
so we were talking about that and some of you guys and I appreciate
y'all sharing your opinion even if it differs from mine but some
of you guys were like oh that's a terrible idea that's not how
you do it oh you trying to be like JST okay and I was like you
know what if you think that I don't saying, "Then uninstall,
don't come back to the >> What did he say? >> And
so we were talking about that and some of you guys, and I appreciate
y'all sharing your opinion, even if it differs from mine, but
some of you guys were like, "Oh, that's a terrible idea. That's
not how you do it. Oh, you trying to be like JST, okay?" And
I was like, "You know what? If you think that I don't understand,
then uninstall. Don't come back to the stream." Right. >> Okay.
No, no, it was just lag. I'm just expressing that it's frustrating
that they're not even giving me uh uh the the viewer isn't giving
me kind of the the leeway to to try things. >> Wait, what
what was like me? I don't even understand. I don't even know.
>> Um Oh, yeah. Hold on. >> Oh, okay. >> Which
friend do you have? >> I think Kate would be okay with
me giving a [__] >> or taking a dick.
>> Not with me getting a [__] or giving a dick.
Uh, the S20. >> I'm pretty sure that's true. >> This
one overheats all the time. >> I'm not even kidding. >> Hold
on. >> You asked. I answered.
>> I need to No. Can you break this down? What the did
he just say? >> Uh, he said his wife with him being
but not with not cheating with another
>> I think Do Can you do the thing that that Counterpoint
does? Can you make a Microsoft Paint about this? >> I can't.
I could explain to you how Nick abusing his wife really isn't
that big a deal and you've probably made your point at this point.
You should actually just move on and stop pointing it out. Stop
talking about it. Actually, I could do that. No, I could I could
do that for Nick. I could I could totally sweep Nick being abusive
to his wife. Yeah, >> 100%. If you need a counterpoints,
you know, like behavior.
>> Is he revealing that he's >> what
uh
I don't think so. >> Wait, what is what is he saying here?
Can you start it over? >> Hammer. He's saying Kate would
be comfortable with it. Hold on.
>> would be comfortable with it. >> I think Kate
would be okay with me giving a [__] or taking a dick,
>> but not with me getting a [__] or giving
a
pretty sure that's true. >> This one overheats all the
time. So, >> I'm not even kidding. >> Like, uh, >> You
asked. I answered December or >> I get it. >> Um,
I guess January the new one's come out. Yeah,
>> he can be with a guy to know what it's >> but
he can never be pleased by another person. I
>> I can't tell. Um, the thing's not working, but I can't
tell if that's because Is it just your avatar that's not working?
No. Uh, the site is broken right now, it seems like. Oh, >> okay.
That's okay. >> Oh, no. Hold on. Hold on. I'm fixing it.
It was uh It hadn't refreshed the login. I got it. I got it.
Why is he wondering >> what Amaranth would Why is he telling
his chat what what Emma would be okay >> I don't know.
Nick's a pretty radically honest guy. He's just being real. Being
a real one. Okay. >> Yeah. Okay. Sure this is lined up
in OBS. Nope. Not lined up at all. >> I'm sorry. I've watched
the clip of the fat version of us like doing a podcast together
and I just had like a a high expectation of what it would be
like when I joined stream again. >> Okay. I'm not that
funny. Sorry, I'm not that funny. So, you expect to be laughing
a lot. It's just not gonna happen. Okay, that fat guy. Very funny
>> He is so funny. Who the is that? >> I have no
idea. You You found the clip. How am I supposed to know who it
is? >> I don't know. I don't know. It's just I just be
finding So, not fat enough. No.
No. I'm feeding him a lot and it's not >> Um, Porter Beller,
I have no idea why you brought it up. I'll link if you look.
I think it's in content suggestions or something where the link
is. You want to look? I I'm probably not going to look into it
right now. I'll be honest. I >> We're trying to make it
through all the chorus to >> I support what Pisco said.
I think this is a huge advertising campaign for Chorus. I can't
imagine how many people requested to sign up saying, "Holy, I
can actually make some money and promote my content and use their
resources. I I think it's been great for Chorus. I think for
money pouring into the space, I'm concerned that people might
be
>> to be dragged into this. And I think also the missing
story here is that Taylor is like >> projecting what she
would do if she got money, you know, cuz how else could you come
up with this weird scenario cuz there's no evidence of anyone
changing
>> real Pisco is just like every time I speaks, Pisco is
like, "Come on, dude. Really? Come on, dude. Really? You really
said you really saying this right now, bro? Every single time
I speak, he's just like, you're not serious right >> opinions
in anyway. And it me off because people like Olivia are being
called out for supporting Alyssa Slotkin. I think back in May,
she tweeted out, "I really like Alyssa Slot." They're like, "Of
course she does. This is why because she was paid by Chorus."
Look at all the signs behind me. People have been questioning
me for years. How you don't like Biden. No way. You can't like
these people. I do. I I And I'm not paid to say that. It's and
it so it undermines all of the support that people like me and
Olivia have for these candidates that they might other people
might disagree with. >> Oh my god. >> I close your
eyes. >> I'm sorry. The fat guy in that podcast is higher
than Hassan on the list of um Rolling Stones like most influential
>> Yeah, he's got >> his name is Caleb Pierce.
He he does have shing
going to dox your job at [__] quiznos.
>> The baristas in his audience, they pay his mortgage.
They're not backing you. >> I had no idea. I've never seen
this guy before. He's somehow one of the most influential people
in the world. >> According to this list, the guy with a
million followers is more influential than me. What did I do
to pull off the Rolling Stones? >> Can you pull up pull
up the clip so people see what fat you could do?
Where? You linked me the clip before. I don't even know. Hold
on. Give me a second. >> Oh, it's it's pinned on my Twitter.
>> I probably put it Oh, okay. Hold on.
Post irony. Cat post irony. Hold on. Hold on. >> Also,
you're going to hate me for this, but he is obese, but he's like
conventionally attractive. I'm pretty >> like months ago
on the internet, he said, "I don't know about the rest of you
guys." Trying to like rally other people in the comments. >> He
goes, "I don't know about the rest of you guys, but this guy
looks to me like he broke into a bakery and ate all the
You're soft. You're so far out of your league. I want to reply
and be like, I'll kick you with a gun. Ate all the pies like
like an 18th century limick. >> This is what DJG thinks
is going to happen anytime they call me fat on Twitter. This
is like their thought process is like the >> I will kill
you to death.
>> It's not fair. >> You just tweet his address.
>> I'm serious. It's child's play for you in the sandbox.
I'm at the gun store. >> You swat him. >> Please
don't make me tweet the address of the quiz knows you work at.
Looks like this guy broke in and ate all the >> Looks like
this guy broke and ate all the pies. I'm going to have with your
>> Okay, except that part. >> Broken and ate all
the pies. >> Your father's going to be eating a pie. That's
for damn sure. >> Yeah. Why don't you break your mouth
into my ass and lick my butthole? You loser. I'm sick. And he
thought he was William Shakespeare. >> He's like, "Anyone
else?" >> Everyone in the replies to my is my >> You're
in the wrong neighborhood. >> You're going to get jumped.
Roll the windows up and lock the doors cuz there are hundreds
of thousands of mentally ill baristas that are ready to mobilize
whenever I say the word. >> If they're not the boy genius
concert, they're at my mention and they will fight you. And the
Doc Martens are laced up. I've got sheays that are so you need
to be careful cuz the guys from AutoZone are not doing the same
for you. >> It It is their part that are funny. Okay. And
the laughter from her is funny. And the Doc Martens are laced
up. Was that was a line, but I don't have enough fleg in my throat
like ever to laugh like this. >> No, they surely are not.
They don't do it like that at the Best Buy. >> Believe
it. >> The Genius Bar inside Best Buy, >> by the
way. And so you're in danger. I don't know about the rest of
you guys. I do know about the rest of them >> and they
love me. You can try to rally them. They pay my mortgage. >> What
if I showed up to your house with a >> What if >> right
now? What if I have a katana
and I show up to the unemployment office when you're there for
your trip? >> Oh my god.
>> Okay. All right. >> I love at the end where he's
like, "What if I show up at the gym?
What if?" And you're doing the stair master on high intensity.
What then? >> Okay. Who
>> Who is the person in the top right of your screen? What's
the What's her name? >> Her name?
>> It would be your left. your your left but the top right
of your camera. It's the green one. >> Oh, that's uh also
Brooks. >> There you go. Not a grifter. >> Wait,
I want to respond to something though. I because like I hear
you. I love your positivity and I love that you you respect and
I think that you do respect your fellow content creator but and
I think that um you know maybe there is a bit of a self-report
and what Lorenza stating especially I haven't looked into this
allegation that she receives money from the same or at least
some entity that she's affiliated with receives money from the
same um >> I can speak
uh but I don't think it's a leap of logic for people be like
huh look at this money like see the connection there as leftwing
people I think we understand that money can have a particularly
corrupt corrupted influence on on people on ideologies on
>> political discourse and so I don't think it's such a
le >> no no IR is arguing the opposite of this what are
we doing Pisco come on >> for Taylor to suggest now she
hasn't tied it to any specific editorial control or ideologicical
orthodoxy so agreed with you totally on that but on the mere
notion that money influences people to act um I don't think that
that's such a >> sleep don't you think she should have
to at least be able to point to something even as even just she
can't connect the dots. Just something anything at all to make
these accusations. That's like
>> uh Can I see Have we recorded the messaging check-ins?
Can I see what the messaging check-ins are like? I'd love to
see the messaging check-ins for the first eight weeks or something.
Just throw those up in a thing and we'll see if those talking
points from the messaging check-ins align at all with any political
ideology. Right
now, they won't do that. I don't actually expect them to do that
because I expected to obviously out them as like clear Democrat
operatives and I I I understand they don't want to do that. Okay.
But I'm just saying like stop acting like I'm the here when you're
just lying without solid evidence. Without solid evidence it's
just hey isn't this kind of weird and then you have a 60 paragraph
article about that. It's like well maybe but like is did anything
happen? And that's why the article is like kind of a little bit
misleading and a little bit more like attacky and hit pacey because
there isn't a direct connection that she can point to and say
this is why it's bad. But to be clear, IRI $100,000 a year will
absolutely
even if it's not being paying someone to change their opinion,
they're going to feel obligated to at least align with the people,
especially if they're small. >> For a small content creator,
yes, but the small people are not getting $8,000. I guarantee
it. They're probably getting 1,200 bucks a month. It's not gamechanging
money. >> Is that is 1,200 bucks the exact amount I was
getting from PV?
>> What does that mean? That's not 1,200 is gamechanging.
That's like enough to quit your job if you live in the Midwest.
>> it's most people's rent, >> which most people
who are like totally
>> That is not enough to quit your job if you live in the
Midwest. That is not how cheap rent is in the Midwest. That's
a >> Yes, it is. All of these losers, they're like they
share a single house, like a single farmhouse with like 12 individuals.
All of them take turns like showering one time a week. Yeah.
They could quit their job and live there in the Midwest. Whatever
goes on in Kentucky. Yeah. >> Okay. Maybe Kentucky. >> The
smaller guys. I'm saying >> I agree with you, I need to
if they're going to make the specific allegation that there's
ideological re >> Okay. I uh I am tired, guys. I'm going
to end the stream. I We went way over time. Charlie, thank you
very much for very much for showing up. I'm like uh I'm starting
to fade to get sleepy.
>> Okay, so have a good night, guys. I'm very tired.
Okay, I will be back. We will be back. Lamato.
Okay, have a good night everybody.
>> W stream be back tomorrow. All right. I I might watch
this off stream. I think I am going to watch it off stream. Okay.
So, love you guys. We'll be back tomorrow. Raid. No raids. >> What
the heck are you saying? D. Are we speaking some Spanglish?